According to server right now,
lots to look at in this room to lots of
skulls and things we can.
This is a,
a video that someone did with Greg
Giraldo,
Drag Greg Giraldo doing standup and
ranting while they played music in the
back
ground for those you don't know,
that didn't know a great draw.
The overdosed.
And uh,
today he died.
Okay.
So if you didn't know Greg Giraldo,
very funny,
very smart,
very clever.
Standup comedian,
uh,
passed away and they're there talking
about it on the news today.
So I guess it's official.
Sucks.
What can you say?
He's a very nice guy.
I didn't know him that well.
I knew who I was on news radio.
He was on a show,
um,
I forget the name of it,
but his set was right down the street
from mindset.
So I hung out with them,
you know,
quite a few times.
Super Friendly,
very nice guy.
Very smart.
You know,
he just,
uh,
I don't know what happened.
I know he had had some substance things
in the past,
but a thought,
I don't know.
Who knows?
I don't know if this was an accident,
if you know,
if he just was partying,
I don't know,
cm on the roast,
the Hasselhoff.
I know a lot of people noted something
about him that seemed different than
normal,
but when they say it seemed very coked
up coked up the quote unquote style
wise.
But I,
you know,
I,
I didn't,
I wouldn't say that cancer that I looked
coked up and I've never done cocaine.
Exactly.
People always say Rogan get a lay off
the coke zero coke dot.
I've never even done coke once.
I've never done coke.
And Tom Green is with us.
Ladies and gentlemen,
if you don't know,
and I'd never done sound of this man's
voice to my right.
Yeah,
this is,
this is this guy to be here.
But uh,
but it was nice to be able to listen to
some of his comedy today on this.
Yeah.
It's mostly a sad occasion.
He has stuff.
He was a good dude.
He was awesome on roasts,
on rose who would destroy guys just
perfectly where there was nothing they
could do.
The leary did that to him on tough
crowd.
Yeah.
That was the most amazing thing I've
ever seen on video.
And he wasn't even an asshole about it.
He could have been way more of an
asshole about it.
He was actually,
he did it with a lot of reserve,
you know,
he was a very nice guy.
It's been a tough year for.
Could Robert Schimmel passed away as
well and.
Yeah.
No,
I,
I just,
uh,
you know,
can I change the topic now because I'm
getting upset if you get me upset.
I have to say our sponsor were sponsored
by fleshlight.
Yes.
Yeah,
I know.
It's A.
First of all,
this is cool to be here.
It's exciting to be here.
Well,
the reason for having me up to the show.
Thank you for being our mascot.
If it wasn't for you,
I would've never even thought to have
done this.
And I went over to your house when you
have me over your house for your show.
And he has.
This is what we're doing here.
We have like a couch rest with
microphones.
We have a desk that I bought at z
Gallerie.
Yeah,
this is awesome.
It's fucking as low rent as you can get
this cool logic tech,
webcam.
But Tom has like a serious,
serious setup at his place.
His place is.
Don't be showing everybody our secrets,
man.
But this is,
this is a whole different system you
guys have here,
which is cool though.
It's cool to watch and see.
I'm seeing how you're broadcasting here.
Our audio is terrible for the longest
time,
so we had to tighten it up.
So uh,
people complained and we listened.
So we went out and bought all this
fucking crazy equipment and we've got it
down.
Now we have new microphones,
but just try them yesterday.
Oh,
these are new microphones.
Is that we went to mix up the mix use
for sure.
Fifty eight.
I don't remember the exact.
It's silver or something?
Sure,
sure,
sure.
Make sure smp,
look that up on Google.
Everybody.
We are now on some audio technica
microphones and seem to be much better
on my show.
I don't have the headphones because we
were trying to make it like it's not a
radio show.
This is like a radio show.
I did a radio show in college at Ottawa
University at ch.
You owe 89 point one FM.
Look that up.
It's just an element to the
conversation.
When you hear each other's voice and
hear your voice right there in your ear,
it's like you're.
You're,
you're sure secret is definitely the
double cassette player that we used to
though.
What's that?
Doubled our secrets are tech secrets of
how we run this laser disc players and
devil crap they got running.
They're running youtube videos off on a
track and a battery operated only.
You don't want any interference.
It's,
it's very,
um,
what's the word?
When something's all helter skelter,
we're a gorilla smorgasbord of wires to
ridiculous pile of shit together.
No previous knowledge.
You could see the evolution of the
podcast like,
like Amoebas becoming fish and you can
watch the whole thing.
We owe it all to Amazon,
to Amazon.com
one click as a motherfucker.
You know,
what do you need?
We need one of these.
Bam,
but this is fun.
Like I didn't,
I didn't,
I didn't in college,
I did my radio show right in it with a
phone in show and we'd go,
go.
I'd go there every Friday night at
midnight.
It was called the midnight caller.
I did the show for six years.
Uh,
not,
not even when I was in high school.
And then after,
when I was in community college,
I took a television broadcasting at
Algonquin college in Ottawa,
Canada,
named after the Algonquin Indians.
Now I'm,
I've always been curious about
television broadcasting.
When you take a course like that,
what do they have you do?
Do you pretend to be like a newscaster
or.
It was mostly,
it's mostly technical,
like it wasn't on camera.
There was one on camera course,
but it was mostly like editing,
video editing,
lighting,
photography,
how to work a video camera,
how to set all your technical stuff.
And we had,
we had,
we had one broadcast news writing course
and we had,
uh,
some single camera video production and
film type courses,
but it was mostly tech.
Well,
mostly technical.
It must be hard as fuck to keep up.
Like if you,
if you learn how to video edit from a
few years ago,
you know,
graduated a few years ago now you go to
today we were learning how to do it on
three quarter inch video cassette.
The video tapes are this big.
You put them in this job and it's like,
you know,
come to a b roll too to videotapes.
Then it moved.
Then we got high eight.
This was before computers editing,
computer editing.
You know there was,
they had abbots and stuff,
but not at the school.
They were too expensive at that point.
I edited it ever paintbrush.
Paintbrush.
Oh yeah.
Starting off the paint brush.
It's really.
Movies on paintbrush is unbelievable.
What you can do now,
right?
That's what's so exciting.
A fucking iphone.
That's the most incredible thing.
You can produce something attached.
Music to it.
Edit it all on your phone or your
fucking phone man.
D,
it's amazing.
It's like weird.
We're in strange,
strange times.
Know I'm getting the new iphone within
the next couple days just because I am
my friend.
Just got it and I'm jealous.
Yeah.
It's an envious thing.
That's.
So that's the motherfucker have device.
He picks it up.
He's shooting.
Hi def video.
You know you can talk.
You can touch screen.
Oh you have when you touch the screen
and you've got one already to non Brian
and are super.
Do you have one too?
I have the old oldest iphone.
My iphone is the old one.
Oh,
you got it.
He has a crank on it.
Man.
That thing runs on wood loan from your
resolutions to 60 photos are insane.
Unbelievable.
Yeah.
It's just amazing that we've got a
device like that.
You know?
I've got no doubt that is some serious
star trek shale.
It slowly crept up on us from the
Motorola Razor to a Microsoft office
wants and then when it gets this iphone,
I mean that is a fucking home computer.
I can no longer be proud of this.
This way.
I used to feel about this.
Well it still allows some old long as
you keep the case on a piece.
A lot of people swear on the show.
Yeah.
He can swim.
Some old fucker says some old piece of
shit is what this is.
That's a sad thing about the analogy and
that's only a few months old,
right?
This is two years old.
Soundboards.
Have you played these soundboards?
No.
Oh,
you know,
I did.
The imt pain.
Yes.
Download.
I enjoy that.
I enjoy doing the imt pain APP.
We're talking obscure iphone apps.
Yeah,
that's a good one.
It's an auto tune.
So you've always some from your time in
broadcasting school to,
to now you've always been really
involved in the technology of the,
behind the scenes stuff.
You've always,
you're not kind of figured I was when I
was,
I was in high school and I thought it'd
be fun to do a TV show someday,
is basically what I thought.
I was watching David Letterman at night,
you know,
and I was thinking,
man,
that would be the most fun thing to ever
do.
I was thinking,
you know,
and little did I know,
but that it's a lot of fun doing this
stuff.
But the thing is,
as you know,
sometimes sometimes not,
but you know,
the thing is,
is,
uh,
you know,
so you know,
no one's ever going to let me do a show.
I'm going to have to go do a show at the
public access station,
will make her own show,
you know,
we went,
I went to school and learned how to make
the videos,
went to the public access station,
started the show,
lasted for seven years when you were
very popular because of your public
access show.
That's what got you started off.
You're also rap star to them.
That's basically what got picked up by
MTV was the public access show.
And it had a Canadian rap group.
Yeah.
That was before the public access,
right.
That was one of.
Okay.
Wrapping people.
They see this man and he's very white
and he has a beard and he's very.
I'm from Ottawa,
Ottawa living.
Very polite.
No,
no.
He's a bad ass rapper.
Yeah.
Tom Green wrap his fucking ass was
listening to your shit today,
man.
You have anything on youtube that you
can throw it right here?
Let me hear it.
Let me hear a Tom Green grass.
I'd love rap music,
man.
Yeah.
I take shit for it.
I make beats and I have.
I've also see that's the other thing.
Before I started doing the video editing
and wanted to do that,
I make beats at home.
So I had like my own little Atari
computer hooked up to a,
a Chi sampler and a keyboard and camera
with you playing it right now.
Oh,
this is,
this is a,
you're a,
you're playing something.
It actually,
it's,
it's Kinda funny when you play music
because we recorded the song,
you know,
20,
22 years ago or something like that.
And we were kids,
teenagers,
teenagers.
And this is us walking around downtown.
What is you tell me what it to you.
I'm the one in the red jacket and I made
the music,
which is essentially a sample and you're
the one who wants to call it,
but you miss it.
Give me a.
that's my friend Greg.
Greg Campbell.
And uh,
and we uh,
guys are from Ottawa,
from Ottawa.
And uh,
so it was fun.
We got,
we actually got a record deal when we
were in high school and the video,
the song and the video was playing on tv
and everything.
It was a very exciting time,
uh,
for two young rappers from Ottawa.
A good.
This video will won the 1992,
a much music video award.
Cmv a award you performed live on the,
uh,
on the CMV va awards.
And I covered myself with a shaving
cream on for no reason and got up in the
lens of the camera,
covered myself in shaving cream.
So we weren't like the sort of hard core
auto tune this yet.
Have you tried to like that's rapping?
Walking through the grocery store.
I love public enemy,
but this is,
this is old though.
Getting here.
My new,
my new shit.
I can we get some new shit?
I Dunno.
Probably floating around.
I don't know.
This is,
this isn't the one to look at it.
This is the one to look at it.
This is really good.
Ben.
I've had,
I've had a lot of fun,
surprising rappers that have come on my
web shop.
Actually,
that's a funny clip you could show.
Oh,
well you,
and maybe you can go look at it on
Youtube,
go to this place because he starts
cracking up
in sort of a funny moment,
you know,
where he's uh,
and uh,
you know,
what?
Did you initially want to be a rapper
before you became a comedian?
No,
not really.
No.
I was like,
I was in high school and uh,
I thought it was a,
it was a fun thing to do on stage at the
assemblies was,
was,
you know,
you had to,
the data band battle of the bands
nitrate,
it was an excuse to get up on stage.
So we made this rap group.
I liked listening to it,
you know,
I was listening to like,
nobody knew what rap music was in my
high school.
Everyone was listening to mainstream
music.
I was listening to boogie down
productions,
Nwa,
public enemy,
you know,
which was not tribe called quest.
These groups weren't really mainstream
yet in,
on the radio in Canada and in the
eighties and nineties.
But uh,
but yeah,
so,
but you know what I was thinking about
this the other day,
rap music back then is kind of like,
it kind of provided what the Internet
provides now,
which is a glimpse into other parts of
the world,
other places,
you know,
here,
here it was,
we were in Canada and we're listening to
these songs coming out in New York,
coming out.
You'll boogie down productions of the
South Bronx and we're listening to them
telling all these tales of life on the
streets in the South Bronx and you're
listening to this,
you're going on a cassette,
you know,
and you're listening to in your walkman
on the way to school and no criminal
minded the record and you're like,
Oh man,
listen to these stories,
you know.
And so that's A.
Yeah,
I was thinking about that driving over
here today.
It's Kinda,
it's,
it's kind of sad because in a way that
might be something that disappears from
music now,
you know,
because of the Internet,
maybe that's going to screw up music.
Let's not be negative as well because we
don't have to go to music now to get
those kinds of,
you know,
store.
I guess we would listen to them on the
Internet.
I think that anything good is going to
stick around.
There's not going to be anything that's
awesome that's going to go away.
You know,
everybody's like,
oh,
this is going to be the death of music.
How can anything be the death of music
when everybody loves music.
That's ridiculous.
It's like he'll be a desk of comedy.
I guess I just sort of more and more
curious to see how it will affect it or
how it'll evolve.
It'll be good.
Well,
now there's so many more places that
people will want to make music and just
distribute their music to have access.
It's perfect.
It just us,
we can do this.
The fact that we can do this and just
broadcast talking over the Internet.
This is just.
You can.
You can become famous from bands.
That little kid,
the one that's saying that covered the
one in l one the l and gave a record
deal.
That was brilliant.
Dude,
that was like some that gave me
goosebumps.
I listened to that kid saying it gave me
I mean my whole family listen to it.
I was like,
this is incredible.
It's so fucking talented and he's in a.
he's in a high school.
Like not even was it even high school?
No.
Middle School.
And what was cool about the video was it
was,
it was all girls listening in the
background.
You could see the girls were into it.
They were crushing,
crushing on him.
That was cool.
Couldn't help themselves.
They were like,
they're a little moistening while
they're sitting up there like 13.
It was,
it was interesting.
This one girl was going,
they couldn't believe it,
you know,
that's sort of the that we have to play
play that man.
Find that shit and that sort of.
We,
we're not gonna play the whole thing for
people who does this.
The fucking music show.
Yeah.
You know what?
Fuck ups the go find it in high school
though to get up on stage.
Wasn't an ellen say something or do
something that everybody in the entire
school know staring at your leg and
Michael J.
Fox in the back of the future playing
the guitar on the stage like you're from
outer space or something.
Weird pressure that is for children to
want to stand out like that.
Like that's got to be so strange for
kids.
I don't remember the feeling myself,
but if you wanted to be some sort of an
act or something and you were 10 and you
were in school and you saw some girl
that was on a show and she was 10 and
you're like,
what the fuck?
How come I can't be on that?
Yeah,
exactly.
It's a terrible way to be raising kids,
thinking about getting the most
attention possible for almost nothing,
like instantaneously become famous.
So everything that your parents,
you know,
all the character that gets developed
from hard work.
That's all nonsense.
I made it already banged.
Shut up 14 and made it.
Yeah.
They put too much pressure on people.
Look at Lindsay Lohan,
especially in this day and age now where
yeah,
you're seeing it.
It's in your face all the time and oh
man,
you could swear dude all the fucking
time and shoving down their throats.
Okay.
Shrill.
We're shoving in.
The strangest thing about Hollywood high
was tricking the very people that make
it,
you know,
there's the grand conspiracy theory is
that like,
man,
you know,
the Hollywood is trying to condition us
to be like,
like subservient to our government man
and be patriotic,
but no,
Hollywood is giving you what you want to
see.
Holly was given you what you want to see
and they're doing what they like to.
They're,
they're making the kind of stupid shit
that they like to watch.
You know,
it's like the people that are creating
it or just as much of a victim of the
conditioning as the people that they're
selling it to.
People don't realize that they think
it's some grand scheme.
No supply and demand.
Yeah.
People want to see a sex tapes and then
see the people go do shows and watch
their lives and sort of see everything
and know everything.
Right.
Do You Watch Jersey shore?
I,
I've seen it.
I've only seen him once,
but I,
I enjoyed it a lot.
I found it.
I found it very.
Uh,
I laughed a lot watching the show.
I can see why people watch.
Those guys are pretty funny too.
Right?
Is that,
that's,
that's.
I've only seen it once ever hamming it
up to the camera there having a good
time.
You're watching people,
you know,
you're being voyeuristic right into a
completely different world.
Like I'm so stuck with the hills though
and everything like that.
I don't buy the Jersey shore.
Like,
I almost think everything's fake now.
Typically it's all set up,
but I don't care.
It's encouraging bad behavior.
There's still,
even if it's fake,
it's like these people like wow,
you,
you watch it.
It's like watching a national geographic
special on some fucking tribe.
Did they found the jungle seemed like
humans,
but it's pretty funny man.
And all they're trying to do is get the
dicks.
It's really kind of funny because it's
real.
It's real.
I mean that really is what that guy's
doing is just trying to fucking get it
every night.
Different girls all over the place.
He's showing you his abs and he's going
to clubs at girls are going,
I mean,
it's working,
it's working.
He's pulling it off and it's working.
I think the thing that's bizarre about
all the reality TV,
those not to overanalyze it.
I guess maybe I,
maybe I'd be overanalyzing and at that
point,
but we're talking about my broadcast and
course they taught us about,
you know,
documentation and making documentary.
We had a documentary film of course,
and they talk about when you put a
camera on something,
right,
it changes what you're filming,
right?
So you can never really make a true
documentary of anything because as soon
as you put the camera on it,
it's going to change what's going on.
Like in this case,
you put the camera on all these kids in
Jersey shore,
right.
And then are like,
okay,
we gotta go crazy for the camera.
So they go for getting in fights or
true.
So then it's going to.
And then people are gonna Watch that and
it's gonna get worse and worse than
that,
people are gonna have to get more
fights.
People going to start,
you know we're going to snuff film
television.
I don't think we'll get to that point.
People don't want to see that kind of
negative stuff.
They want us,
they want to be fascinated by orange
will recall faces of death.
They want the want the couple to make
out and then close the door.
That's where they want it to stop.
Yeah.
It's all fascinating to me,
man,
because it's so easy to change behavior
by just putting a camera on it.
If that's really the case,
if all you have to do is add a camera at
the fact that other people are going to
get to see it and it changes everything.
No,
they're still doing this.
Even if they're faking it and acting it
out.
I don't care.
You're still doing all this stuff on the
show and to me,
look,
it's.
It's like some sort of a national
geographic special.
It really is.
I want to watch it more.
Yeah.
I can't help myself.
I have to watch it more.
So it really is.
So yeah,
they think they just get used to the
camera and that's just the way they
would be living life.
I grew up with people like that.
Their chimps,
chimps,
chimps out there with gold chains,
Onga and that is out there running
around.
Not giving a fuck about how the world
works.
That's exactly what it's like on the
Jersey.
There's.
I knew dudes from back when I was in
high school that did not give a fuck how
the world works.
Yeah.
All they want to do.
They worked,
they did.
They were electricians.
They would work and then when they get
off work they'd want to get fucked up
and go get laid and they didn't know
anything.
They didn't know what was going on.
They have no idea.
Didn't give a fuck.
Did pay attention.
What am I gonna do with my fall fucking
politics?
Mcguire.
I'm getting my Dick Suck.
Come up.
What am I going to do here?
Oh my God.
I do follow politics.
That shit.
That shit ain't real.
Yo.
I said I really.
I grew up with dudes like that.
So when I see them putting cameras on
people like that and go,
oh no,
no,
they gave these savages a fucking
camera.
They gave them air time.
Actually now I'm starting to.
I'm a little mad at myself that I
haven't watched it more.
I think I've been withdrawing a little
bit from a television need to last
couple of years purposely not watching
anything other than CNN actually is
pretty well.
I don't even watch American.
I watched American idol because
everybody watched it.
I don't watch that.
I don't want no more.
I used to like watching the people suck
in the beginning,
but then I get them.
I'm like,
what's wrong with you?
You sick?
Fuck.
You want to watch people fail.
Was like,
oh wow.
How was that fun?
You know,
every now and then you see one.
That's brilliant.
Well guess what?
I'll find that one on youtube.
Okay.
Tell me some amazing thing like that.
Susan,
what was her name?
The one could really sang Susan.
Susan Boyle,
Boyle.
Susan.
Susan Boyle.
Yeah.
That was fascinating.
I mean that was,
that was really incredible.
I mean,
she had an amazing voice,
but how many hours do I have to sit
through of bullshit before I get to that
and it was the and it was a perfect
moment and it was just sort of the
perfect,
perfect thing that happened here yet.
But the thing is I don't like to.
I used to like the beginning when they
were a fucking up to at the beginning
and they making fools of themselves,
but now it seems like the people coming
in are coming and I can't watch that
anymore.
Yeah.
And another musical sucks on the radio
now because it all comes out of that
same thing.
Right?
It's all coming out of that same funnel.
It's like,
well we gotta we gotta do a really good
Jefferson airplane impression,
you know,
you think so.
I can't stand them.
The new music.
There's always good stuff,
man.
You just got to find it.
There's just so much.
Well that's the problem.
See,
I don't know how to find it.
I,
I agree.
I know there is good stuff because there
is good stuff that I find in here
sometimes,
but just going through life now,
like when you're walking and you're in
an elevator or you're walking through a
mall or you're listening to the radio or
the mainstream stuff,
it's all the shit.
Yeah,
that's true.
You don't have to.
I don't.
I don't listen to college radio anymore.
I don't know what the station is and so
I don't know how to find the cool
underground stuff.
He'd do Pandora all.
Yeah,
I do.
I do do that,
but I don't know what to type into a
search because people
know when you're.
When you're,
when you're in school and stuff and
you're around people,
but I mean I've met him in my living
room.
The loss of the DJ,
the loss of the Dj,
the Dj to me is one of the things I miss
the most about the radio,
about growing up and listening to the
radio.
I would listen to guys and listen to the
shit that they like to listen to and you
were cool guys and they would like.
There was a,
Charles Laquidara,
was this guy who used to do the big
mattress show on,
I think it was WBCN BCRC cozy back in
Boston and it was like this morning show
where he would go on and it was a comedy
show and they would fuck around,
but he plays songs too,
you know,
and he played the shit that he wanted
here.
That's funny.
I like that guy's point of view and
that's the music he likes.
There's this guy in my field toe mark
parenteau was the afternoon Dj and he
was like a big supporter of comedy too.
We always did like comedy competitions
and shit and he would play the shit that
he wanted to hear.
I'm like,
you got a sense of like,
this cool guy likes this music.
You know,
it tells you,
you know why he likes this song,
what's so bad ass about it?
Check it out.
Bam.
And he plays it.
It's like you're having a show that's a
show.
That's a show.
What they're doing now is just sticking
all sorts of songs that they think they
can get you to pay attention to
together.
And then,
you know,
they throw him in there,
there's no one,
there's no one personality behind it.
It's not,
there's no radio djs.
The radio djs really have much of a
choice in what they put on their voice.
You know,
there's an art to being a true fan of
the music and going out there and
listening to different stuff and
collecting your own,
you know,
your own favorites and saying,
look,
this cool shit that I got.
That's what I meant.
That's what I'm trying to say.
I'm,
it's right there.
Because it's like now you listen to the
radio.
It's all been focus group tested out.
This is this,
this sounds like this,
this is so and so from American idol,
American idol.
The sounds like American idol.
This all sounds like a.
and it all sounds the same to me.
Brian and I have very nice sound like an
old guy now.
I sound like an old guy,
right?
Because I just turned nine years old.
I just turned 39 and I got one like an
old guy one year,
but you know from 40.
And I'm starting to sound like my dad
saying none of the music today is good
to everybody.
It was back when I was.
Everybody says that,
but there's good stuff.
You just have to find it.
It's just hard to do.
Brian and I have very similar tastes and
Brian is always fun to me.
Cool Shit.
Who's always fighting.
He's like,
he's a internet fiend,
so he's always connecting.
So I always look forward to it.
He knew cool shit is fun man.
There's a lot of it out there.
It's just there's so much to sift
through.
So much data and slash or helps me the
most and that,
you know,
just being at a club and hearing a
really good dj and I'll hook up sam,
Sam or whatever,
and then I shit finds me some crashes
and if you don't know,
if you don't have that program on your
phone,
it's the most incredible thing.
You wouldn't even believe it's real.
You hold your phone up to a speaker.
Oh,
he plays the song and it tells you what
the song is.
And unless you buy it on your phone,
sound snap.
Actually let you a song.
So He'd be like,
I told that to edit and he's like,
that's impossible.
It's just trying to tell me about music
chords,
that and that and this.
I'm like,
I'm telling you,
they do it.
That's what it is.
It's just wave forms,
you know,
that's what it does.
It takes the,
takes the song,
it makes it a wave form,
like a picture,
like a Jpeg,
and it just puts it in a database.
Analyze.
Yeah,
analyze it.
And it's like matching fingerprints.
It's actually pretty brilliant how it
works and it's not that big of a deal.
If we even get to know when the
computers take over,
uh,
we even going to know we're not even
going to know.
No,
they're going to take over.
So Dave started with the Tia 81 I think.
What are you doing today?
It's real number.
How would you like to play again,
analyze it in seconds and tell you what
the song is,
listened to it,
analyze it,
break it down to a piece of data and
then spit it back at you with options to
purchase it all in seconds.
And they can do it for,
you know,
practically every fucking song there is
out there.
I've never had a failing me wants to
have you ever had a failing once.
But it was also like a remix version.
So it was other shit mixed up.
You hear a song,
you like it,
you want,
you want to know what it is you have
polled Shazamm up.
It tells you what it is,
downloads it and buys it
for you.
You start asking it in your car seconds
later.
If your car's Bluetooth,
Bam.
It's planning your.
That's amazing.
I want bumblebee song because it's like
when I,
when I was,
when I was doing my wrap group back
then,
I was a teenager,
he was,
we were back then,
it was all about sampling loops,
right?
So you'd find you'd hear loops of music,
breaks of music.
So we'd go into the radio station all
the time.
I was looking for a cool beat breaks and
stuff.
So you hear that you'd always hear stuff
and you wouldn't know what to,
you know what it was.
Then you do that,
you know,
they don't.
But,
you know,
let me ask you a question.
Can I ask you a question?
Okay.
Because I've noticed you have a lot of
Buddhas around the house,
right?
Yeah.
It said.
Okay.
Sure,
sure.
Um,
because I had a Buddha and uh,
I've,
I really like them a lot.
I had one at my house.
It was when I,
when I,
when I got my house,
it was there already.
I didn't get the Buddha.
The Buddha was there already.
It was a fountain,
right?
Because on a pole it was a big
fountains,
but the size of that poster there,
big concrete fountain.
And uh,
I had uh,
a meeting one day with a television
executive at my house.
Okay.
And we went up on the roof of my house
and we had a meeting,
just a discussion,
having a beer,
talking about some ideas,
television ideas.
And we hear this enormous crash.
We go down and the Buddha has just,
for whatever reason the pole is on this
metal pole smashed,
it has fallen,
it is smashed into a million pieces and
gone into my swimming pool.
And I'm looking at it and I'm just
thinking,
okay,
apart from like,
I really miss the thing.
Is that a sign of.
No.
Okay,
good.
No,
it's not like swimming.
There was a donald duck statute's still
a little fall.
And so it's just,
there's no magical property to having
the boot and it's just,
it's just a thing,
a nice thing to look.
I am fascinated by ancient Asian artwork
fascinated by Buddhists and tie Buddhas
and the fact that they've looked that
way for
hundreds and thousands of years and all
these different people depict these
things in the different artistic ways.
And that the Buddha is a character of
peace.
You know,
the,
the idea of these Thai Buddhist to me
means a lot to me.
It give it's,
it's,
uh,
a beautiful artistic representation of
enlightenment and it's calming,
too calming.
I love their art work.
I love Sheeva's.
I love Hindu artwork.
I love,
um,
I love a lot of Thai artwork,
some of the most fascinating stuff.
It's one of the coolest things about
living in La is that you have access to
all these importers.
They import this really,
um,
a lot of this beautiful hand carved
stuff from Thailand,
which you guys ever have a mummy?
Mummy,
mummy and my house like a dead guy
wrapped up.
What'd you morbid man?
It's like,
why?
You know,
I mean I guess if you wanted to like
have it in glass like in a room
somewhere and shit too.
Probably so weird.
So weird message you're sending.
I just don't like the smell of embalming
fluid.
What if it's something that's always
bothered me was like,
if you ever heard of that self
mummification mummification was a
practice is and it's been done several
times by these monks and one of the
things they do is they eat nothing but a
very,
very lean foods.
They eat like seeds and nuts and they go
through rigorous exercise routines for
like three years where they virtually
stripped their body of all its fat and
then they start drinking this,
this crazy a tonic that's,
it's like semi poisonous so it doesn't
kill them but it fucks them up nice and
slowly and it keeps maggots from growing
on them.
Get this.
Then they climb into a sarcophagus when
after they've done this for awhile,
so their bodies like ready to go.
They climbing this sarcophagus and they
close the lid on them and there's just
an air hole and a bell,
so like the guy in the Lotus position,
that new movie with a.
He stays in the Lotus position with the
air hole in the bell and every day if
he's alive he rings the bell and the day
that he doesn't ring the Bell,
they seal the coughing up and then he's
in there for good and he's mummified.
Why modification?
Why do they do that now?
Because they're fucking nuts.
Where are these guys?
Were they still doing this today?
Yeah.
People just legal ramifications for
laws.
Whose laws were.
What were they doing?
I believe it's in Tibet.
Should actually stop.
This is a campaign to stop this crap.
Brian,
onto Google self memification.
No,
because I know that it's something that
has been done.
They have these mummies,
man,
and they've taken the lids off there.
There sarcophagus and there in the Lotus
position,
man,
they're fucking robes on and their
mummies.
It is the creepiest dedication to
whatever it is that you're doing it for.
Fuck.
They're taking it to the next level,
man.
Total dedication.
They're taking it.
They're poisoning the maggots.
Okay.
How about that?
They're.
They're taking some shit that kills the
maggots.
Now,
by the way,
I'm reading this on the Internet.
Who knows how much of this is true?
I might be says it's a form of a
suicide,
so let me ask those suicide.
It takes years,
man.
So there is a lot of stuff on the
Internet that we read that is not true
and that is true.
Now you were talking about the Ufo was
last night at your show,
which was hilarious by the way,
and that's what it was.
Great running into you over there.
We ran into each other at a club.
J Dot Davis is going doing this little
club.
What's it called?
The parlor.
The Parlor?
Yep.
On Melrose.
So a fun,
nice little place,
but the AC was out.
It was whack.
They were.
It was really cool crowd because even
though it was like a fucking 100 degrees
in there,
like literally it was at least 100
degrees in that room.
I can drink like crazy.
It's so high.
It was.
The crowd was very polite.
I felt like I was imposing.
Talking to them,
I felt like I felt bad.
I felt like I was doing something by
making them sit there and watch it.
No,
no,
no.
It was hilarious.
It was awesome.
It was great.
It was a great surprise.
I didn't know you were coming out.
We've been.
We haven't seen each other in a couple
of years.
I have a bunch of questions I want to
ask you because I've started trying to
do standup comedy.
You're up and doing it this year,
but happened to it.
I haven't laughed at some of your stuff
on them and doing it.
I'm not trying to do it.
I'm doing it.
God Damn it.
I'm sorry.
No,
I said,
I said that.
I said sorry for you.
No.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's a whole whole new world,
isn't it?
Uh,
it's a very uh,
but I want to ask you some questions
about that,
but um,
but yeah,
so,
uh,
I'll ask you right now I guess go for it
or were we going to talk a bit more
about the show last night?
Well,
the show last night,
it was a lot of fun.
Bird went up and did a bunch of new
shit.
Oh,
and bill burrs,
a comedy central special airs again this
October first,
I believe it is very fun.
If you haven't seen it,
check it out and it will be good for him
too.
He really wants to get ratings in this
thing because he wants to do more of
them.
And if you're a fan of standup comedy,
Bill Burrs,
one of the best.
He's one of the best guys out there
today.
There's very few guys that like
consistently nail it the way he does.
He's really good.
He's a really.
I went
down there to see bill last night
because I met him at the Montreal comedy
festival and that this is what's been
fun about doing standup as I'm getting
to go to a comedy festival and hanging
out with a bunch of funny people.
Everyone's having a good time.
You know,
I've saw Doug Stan hope up at the
Montreal comedy festival.
He had this awesome party in a carwash,
you know,
it was like a good time.
So he calls it just for spite and he
does it a po opposing the actual camera.
Right?
That's right.
He's not part of the festival and this
was this whole sort of controversial
thing that was going on up there,
but it was actually quite funny because
he had this amazing party in this
carwash right across the street isn't
really great.
Yeah,
it was really cool.
What'd you guys,
what was it like the bar closed,
right.
And then it's like,
okay,
well the bar at the hotel closed and
then everyone said,
well,
you know,
ducks stand hopes.
Having a party in a carwash across the
street,
what you walk out across the street and
now it's,
you know,
three in the morning now.
Right.
So those bars are closed when you walk
crust literally right across the street
from the hotel,
the main hotel for the festival.
There's this like the smallest carwash,
you know,
it's got the garage hoses everywhere and
it was just,
just buckets of beer and we were there
to like seven in the morning or
something like that.
So good time.
Lots people,
a couple of hundred people in there,
in this car wash.
Awesome.
So you just put together a party.
Yeah,
it was really,
it was really good.
But just a move.
But what happens if people drive drunk
and stuff?
I don't think any of them driving taxis
and stuff.
Really.
That's,
that's a nice move.
Good.
You know,
the thing that's cool about it is like,
you know,
so we go over there.
I'm at the Montreal Comedy Festival and
I met bill burn.
He came and saw my show and then last
night I thought I'd let you know I'm
going to go see bill show.
Go see bill show you pop out on stage
unexpectedly.
Next thing you know,
I'm up here at your house.
We're drinking cups of coffee,
delicious coffee and uh,
doing some,
uh,
some Webo vision here.
It's pretty cool.
It is cool.
It's totally twitter.
A couple of times I've said,
hey,
you know,
joe,
check this out.
I'm on the road.
I sent you a couple of my trailers for
my standard.
We see them on Tom Green.com.
Go and Tom Green.com.
Have a look at some of the trailers of
the tour and around doing this,
but for the folks on Itunes,
it's Tom Green live.
If you,
uh,
if you want to find them on twitter,
go at Tom Green live because they can't
see this where it's absolutely Tom
Green.
Live as my twitter.
Still releasing that movie,
that movie a young Pranksters Prank star
yet that we're working on that one
still.
Whoa.
I can't wait for Susan.
It's kind of,
um,
it's kind of,
it's kind of a top secret.
It's not finished.
Well,
I can't really tell you what's about
because I'm not sure I even know yet
because we're still kind of in the
process of finishing it.
Cool.
Yeah.
I want you to do more movies,
man.
I really enjoyed.
Freddy got fingered.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Thank you.
You went out there with that man.
You took a crazy chance.
Yeah,
I think it shocked a lot of people.
They didn't know what to do with it
know,
because it was so out there,
but it was one of the ultimate stoner
movies.
If you're a stoner,
what?
Go get Freddy of people like,
you know,
a lot of people haven't,
haven't really heard enough good reviews
of it.
It's really fucking funny girl that all
day with the baby when the giving birth,
I want to say anymore.
I don't want to ruin it in a way to your
comedy,
but now.
Well let me just,
let me tell you the thing that.
Thank you for saying that,
because you know,
when you,
you get thrust into this situation where
all of a sudden I had an opportunity to
make a movie to write.
I wrote it obviously was trying to make
the stupidest movie we could think of
right now.
Let's make it the stupidest thing ever.
And then,
you know,
the studio at the time had all this
opportunity to make this.
They said,
okay,
they had all these directors I said I
want to direct it to.
So then they let me direct it.
So now I'm swinging blooding babies
around and you know,
jacking off elephants and stuff and you
know,
getting inside deer carcasses and doing
all this stuff.
Right?
And then,
you know,
you're working on this thing for like a
year,
right?
You know,
you're working on this thing for a year
nonstop.
Uh,
you know,
you're casting it,
you're picking all the props,
you're making sure all the way the,
the guts that come out of that deer
carcass looked like rubber to me.
And then the prop guys like,
well,
we're going to put some blood on it and
it's gonna go,
well,
let's see what that looks like.
And they do it and you look at it and
you're like,
no,
it still looks like some rubber.
We got to get some real guts.
And they're like,
well,
we don't know how we're going to make
real guts come out of the carcass when
you cut it.
And then they go off and these are like
people that are professionals,
you know,
and they go off and they come back the
next day and they go,
okay,
we've rigged up this compressed air that
we're going to put in the back of the
taxidermy deer.
You're going to run your knife down.
The slit is going to shoot out real pig
guts that we've got the butcher shop,
you know,
and I'm draped in pig guts and I'm doing
all this stuff right?
And you're thinking,
okay,
this is crazy,
this is going to look crazy.
Then the movie comes out,
everybody like,
you know,
basically,
reams you like,
uh,
you know,
you've never been seen before in your
life at this point,
you know what I mean?
Local papers and people and you and you
feel completely kind of confused about
it,
right?
Because you're thinking,
shit,
I thought it was pretty fucking funny.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
Right.
So then,
but the fun thing about it is after that
initial weekend and the whole sort of
everybody talking about your movie being
crazy and disgusting and all this stuff,
you uh,
you know,
I've been on tour this year doing stand
up and it's been so much fun because
there's a lot of a nut jobs out there in
the world that like,
that let that love the movie and they're
part of my show now.
And when I do my standup,
I do a little guitar at my show in the
middle and I seen a couple like,
Daddy,
would you like some sausage?
I sing that with everybody sings it with
me.
And then people start shouting out some
of their favorite bits.
But I'm surprised it went all across
Australia,
Canada.
Next month I'm going to be in a Toronto
Bellville,
um,
a Hamilton and London,
Ontario,
and uh,
people come to the shows and uh,
you know,
are,
are shouting out all these things from
Freddie.
Got It.
Feels a lot.
I guess what I'm saying is,
thanks for bringing it up.
This is what I used to be out and
actually getting all this positive
feedback about the movie because I was
made to feel like you're a victim of a
pre-internet review system.
It was a bunch of fogy old douche bags
and you know,
the way people looked at things was,
you know,
you couldn't just be when,
what year was pretty good fingered.
It was 2001,
you know,
what the fuck was on the Internet back
then?
You know what I'm saying?
It wasn't the same as 2010 and the thing
doesn't attend.
You get your reviews from ain't it cool
news.com.
That kind of shit.
Like I always go to Fandango or
something.
I get my reviews online.
I want to use this moment as a,
as a real opportunity for me to actually
talk about this for a second.
Okay.
I directed this movie.
I wrote this whole thing and everybody
freaks out on it.
It's Pre-internet,
right?
I the other day I went and I looked at a
netflix.
Okay.
At the end of the reviews of the movies.
Right.
So I did this just two days ago and I
looked at the reviews and Freddy got
fingered and the point of making that
movie was to kind of be polarizing,
right?
It was supposed to be ridiculous.
It was done in a way where I think that
50 percent of the people who watch it
are definitely going to hate it more
than anything they've ever seen in their
entire life.
And that was the goal to,
you know,
in the job is obviously that the other
50 percent of the people are laughing at
the 50 percent of the people that hate
it.
And that's the joke,
right?
So yeah,
I went on Netflix and you're reading the
reviews and it's,
it's pretty much 50 slash 50 people are
giving it either you know,
a good review or the worst review you've
ever read in your life back and forth,
back and forth,
and these people are just arguing with
each other about it.
And here we are 10 years later after I
made this thing and looking at these
people,
having these passionate arguments
completely on opposite ends of the
spectrum.
That's pretty funny.
So I like to go read the reviews on
this.
I really truly believed that at that
movie came out today.
It would be an internet phenomenon.
People will be so into it.
I think it was a fucking fun,
crazy movie.
Red You will.
I'm hoping to make another movie this
year since since he has asked about the
movies.
I'm hoping to make another movie this
year,
which is going to be called insane prank
movie and it's going to be just a bunch
of crazy pranks street stuff,
but you know,
it's going to be sort of a.
well don't get beat up man.
I've been hearing you.
You're telling me you're getting in
fights,
what's going on?
Oh yes,
that's right.
Yeah,
I am.
I've been in two fights.
You're grown,
man.
I won't be around and not get in.
I was defending myself both times.
What happened?
I was attacked both times by who?
I was by strangers both times.
For what reason?
Well,
the first time I was attacked.
Where was it?
Where does taking place?
About two years ago in New York City.
And did the guy know you were Tom Green?
The he was.
He was somebody who knew somebody.
I don't know.
He was somebody who was an acquaintance
of somebody who I knew and now I'm now
I'm starting to get worried about
getting into the details because what
really happened was quite intense.
Quite intense.
Why I'm worried about getting it.
Well,
because you know,
I don't know.
I just thinking now all of a sudden I've
never really talked about this on the
radio in.
That'd be kind of weird.
What's weird when you get in a fight,
beat somebody up.
Tom Green?
No,
he.
He was punched in the head and I
retaliated.
Right.
And then whoop that ass,
you know.
Did you get all up in their beat that
ass essentially?
Yes.
Essentially.
I was not heard.
Probably shouldn't give out the details
because you know,
I just don't get sued.
You're Tom Green.
Well,
you know,
somebody punched me in the head and so I
had to kind of thing.
But then the other solid jaw take a good
shot right there.
Right there.
I had a bump the next day.
It was,
it was itching gray out or did you stand
your ground?
I was actually sitting down.
He punched you when you were sitting
down.
What did you do?
Were you getting blown by his
girlfriend?
Why while you sitting?
I was sitting beside his girlfriend.
You were?
Yeah.
Or a girl that he knew,
but I wasn't really,
uh,
you know,
I was also with a girl who was my friend
who was sitting beside me on this side
and we were all friends and she was
friends with them.
But anyways,
this is the point.
Let's,
let's move past that.
The point is,
as you got in fights,
I got in a fight,
so then the second time around,
okay,
you're a veteran by now.
You're ready to end.
This is actually something I can ask you
about for advice on this because this is
about controlling your temper,
right?
This is about when somebody comes at you
and you know you're.
You are a fighter,
so you know about this stuff,
right?
I don't know about this stuff,
but what happened I,
I go go into this sort of post traumatic
stress disorder,
kind of everything goes in slow motion.
Well,
you know,
that's one of the best things about
learning martial arts is that you become
confident in your ability to defend
yourself,
not you might not always be able to
defend yourself.
You might.
There might be guns and weapons and all,
but you're not going to feel completely
helpless.
You're going to feel like you have at
least confidence.
If you have a chance,
you can do something.
Whereas a person who doesn't know how to
fight it all and has no experience,
it's such a paralyzing feeling when you
in the presence of violence.
So I mean,
you just want to cover up in a ball,
you just want to try to protect
yourself.
You don't know what to do.
So this first occasion had bad feelings.
First occasion happened
and cut to three months.
Maybe six months later I'm walking down
sunset outside Mel's diner that's got
the stitches taken out.
Yeah.
And Somehow,
um,
for some reason somebody comes up behind
me,
I was,
I think I'd actually had a few drinks
that night.
Me and my friends were being somewhat
obnoxious.
Oh,
talking loudly,
being generally idiots on the street.
Yeah.
And some,
some guy saw me being kind of an idiot
and came walking up to me and my friend,
that was Brian and he said,
hey man,
I want to kick your ass right now.
Just like that.
No reason.
Okay.
He said,
I'm going to kick your ass right now.
And this guy was actually smaller than
me,
which I thought was strange in these
coming out of nowhere.
And the word of the dark and there's no
one around right by Poquito mas outside.
Mel Mel's diner on sunset.
I look at him,
my friend looks at him,
he,
my friend says,
are you serious dude?
And he goes,
yeah.
And then my friend for whatever reason
goes okay.
And goes like that.
So then this guy's running at me,
but because of the previous situation,
I'm now in like the slow motion mode.
Like he's coming at me and I've done,
well,
this is not going to.
So I went at him and I,
I just put my hands on his neck,
right?
And I put my hand behind them.
I kind of lowered them down under the
ground and I put my fist up in his face
like this.
And I said,
I don't want to hurt you man.
I don't want to hurt you.
Right.
And he said his leg was kind of flapping
up on the side of my body like this.
And I had him pinned on his back on the
sidewalk.
And he said,
okay man.
Okay.
And I got up and he walked away.
Wow,
so then how for rape joke to the mount
position for those that you don't know
what Tom Green was doing,
grabbing the hand and the bitch,
where's my money grip?
And then he had a fist up.
Yeah.
And it just kind of ended.
It diffused the situation.
Nobody got hurt and uh,
you know,
that's,
I think that's,
I think that's something that people
need to know is that to,
you know,
there is this flash of a moment when
somebody attacks you were,
you kind of go into this animal mode,
right?
And you're not in complete control.
Right.
And then you know,
you gotta you gotta kind of be able to
control that now.
Are you like paranoid
that everyone's going to attack you?
Like,
do you like the,
although less paranoid now because I now
know I got a,
got a,
got that sort of.
It's sort of like a throat on the
ground.
You're always thinking about it.
Right?
Well the other thing is,
is that that only worked because he was
coming at me fast and he was sort of
smaller than me.
I don't think that would've worked if he
was bigger than me.
That would have worked on new.
Anything new,
anything that would work.
You find a lot.
He was probably really,
really drunk and it was just.
To me it was exciting though because I
haven't been in any sort of physical
altercation since I was at a kid.
You don't want that kind of excitement.
If you want to go to Jujitsu class,
Jujitsu,
you get to spar,
you get to go full blast with each other
and trying to kill each other with your
bare hands.
It's awesome.
You get all that shit out and you don't
have to get in fights on there.
On your conflict is there's a certain
amount over a certain amount of
excitement,
primal excitement that comes from.
But it's very dangerous man.
Oh my gosh.
I actually,
when you're an alcohol,
you guys were walking down the street
making a fuck load of noise.
No,
this has become so paranoid about it.
Since then that I've actually kind of
essentially really laid off the sauce a
bit because I realized that,
you know,
although I didn't really kind of.
I got attacked,
right,
but it was due to my own sort of loud,
obnoxious behavior.
That's what I'm saying.
Like you learn from that,
right?
Yeah.
You do.
And drunkenness and things you can do if
you're really loud and in public.
That's a douchey.
It's when you're in your twenties,
being drunk out at the bar and being
crazy.
Yeah.
It's part,
it's part of it.
I just turned 39 years old and I'm
thinking to myself,
that's not cute anymore.
Really.
Totally.
It's not cute.
It's not cute when it annoys other
people.
That's what it is,
you know,
and I never used to think about that
when I was younger.
I just think about it.
I just random fun it.
Woo.
Yeah.
We're having fun.
Who gives a shit and then as you get
older you start going,
wait a minute.
But if we're having fun at other
people's expense,
they shouldn't be fun.
Should be annoying to me too.
I should be embarrassed.
You know,
they learn not to be a Douche bag.
Yeah,
exactly.
And that's exactly what moved that
you're ready to go.
I think you might want to.
I'm going to show you,
we'll go onto my cage in the garage and
I'll show you some counters to be very
careful.
I,
I would.
I would appreciate some self defense.
Not that I want to extend your arm.
You've got to make sure you do it
correctly.
I'd like to take some.
Some Jujitsu.
Crop was fun too.
It's like a combination of things and
they,
they give you like a lot of stuff like
this is what you do on the street when a
guy comes after you,
but you can't prepare for everything on
the street.
You don't really know what the fuck.
If a guy's going to have a gun or a
knife,
you're not going to really know.
You know?
You're better off just getting really
good at any sort of a martial art.
Like you know you're really going to get
good at knife defense.
That's.
Yeah.
That seems like a waste of time
considering no one's ever pulled a knife
on you and your life away from
douchebags.
Keep your life clean.
Let's hope we don't get stabbed.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't be going out.
Practice every day because one day God's
going to have a knife.
There's this fat guy has his website on
all sorts of attacks,
like a knife against a knife,
how he will block this knife and then he
will attack this means up fat.
Fuck Guy's hilarious.
He's completely out of shape and he's
like,
he's actually kind of a half decent
writer,
but totally completely delusional
martial arts guy.
And so,
uh,
he's got these instructional videos
where a guy will come at him with a
knife and he will block this knife and
cut to the guy's body,
go behind him,
and he cuts like major organs and I'm
looking to make.
This is the most ridiculous thing I've
ever seen in my life.
Preparing for a knife fight that will
never have one probably cause of the
preparing for it to take your clothes.
Increasing his odds of being killed by
like $10,000
times carrying knives on them
everywhere.
Challenged asking for a knife,
fight.
He's begging for a knife.
Fight is nuts.
You know what the fuck's wasting their
life?
Preparing for the knife fights.
This is funny.
Sometimes I look down here at this
stream and then I see you and I'm
thinking that I'm looking at you live,
but it's deliberately.
Yeah,
let's not look at it because I don't
want to confuse you.
It was funny.
It was.
It was confusing to me because.
And they'll go off and adrift.
Yeah.
Was,
it was.
Yeah,
it was,
it was like I was,
I was looking at your,
you're laughing over there and I'm like,
wait a minute.
I'm not saying anything funny right now.
Oh wait,
he's not laughing.
That was,
that was a few seconds ago.
Something that was very high tech run a
delay in case you start getting crazy.
Curse our government.
Yeah,
this is cool.
And now,
so we're,
uh,
we're broadcasting on itunes,
itunes,
on the Zune marketplace.
It's on all sorts of different things.
Oh,
this is cool.
This is cool.
I'm now.
So yeah.
So,
um,
stitcher number one in Canada,
a comedy few times on itunes.
Okay.
Yeah.
See,
this is something that Canada,
I'm going to start trying to do a
podcast myself for the first time and I
in starting next week.
So it's going to be fun.
You've always been in that kind of
community access channel like are you
will always make them via.
You actually changed everything when you
had your show on MTV,
in my opinion,
my whole age group,
uh,
I'm 36,
but you took my idea making stupid
little videos and going,
wow,
look what he's doing.
He's actually doing it for real z's on
MTV.
You know,
you've really changed that whole market.
You,
it's pretty,
pretty amazing career that you've had
men.
That was an exciting time.
It was obviously that was most exciting
was just blown.
Brian,
you know,
maybe we wait until the show's over and
as one of the most awkward things,
every driveway or something like that.
Really.
Like when Doug's down opens here,
I was trying to sell it really good
things about them,
but I'm like,
it's so weird saying that he's right
here and it's going to broadcasting in
front of the world.
But a great show though.
You come up to Joe's house,
coffee,
you get a blow job.
I think a lot of people though I think a
lot you've inspired a lot of people are
inspired me to do this man this online.
When I came over to your house,
I'm like,
wow,
oh yeah,
I remember how excited you are about it
and you talk to the,
the.
There was a document or was an
entertainment tonight,
Canada or somebody who was at the house
and you said you were very excited about
and I thought,
well this is cool.
This is maybe maybe this is not a waste
of time doing the show in living room
just so we,
it,
we knew that eventually it was going to
get to the point where the Internet and
the television combined.
It hasn't totally happened yet.
Convert pretty close concert.
Too small a dribble,
you know,
I can get like I have a DVD player that
lets you go to let you go to different
sources and get netflix and.
Yeah.
And even youtube allows you go to
youtube as well and you stream.
I don't know about ustream.
No,
no,
I think I was wrong.
That was youtube here,
but it's just,
it's close.
You know,
you can get the Internet is bringing
content to your television.
It's just doing it through outside
parties now is not quite as accessible
as I would.
Thank you.
I worry that it's going to get all
controlled.
So you end up,
everyone gets some box.
They're watching the internet on their
TV,
but it's not the real internet,
you know,
it's just the stuff that the shows that
get bought by Time Warner cable until
they decide to put on the Internet,
which then all of a sudden you don't
have the Internet.
You have this sort of other way of
distributing and television that's on
demand.
So we're,
it's not free net neutrality,
you know,
you need,
need to make sure that,
you know,
and I don't know a whole lot about it,
but you know,
I was talking about this the other day
with my friend and he said net
neutrality is a big issue right now.
You know,
they're talking about,
well,
since you're in Hollywood,
since we don't know a lot about it,
argue about it.
It's one of us know the points.
So I just think that we got to stop this
man.
That's how we rock it in Hollywood.
Argue about shit we don't even know
about.
Well,
you know,
I was on stage at some guy,
some guy in the audience just decided he
was going to heckle and this is what he
had called.
He goes,
even Stephen Hawking said that the
universe proves there must be a god.
Like he was arguing with me,
angry at me and this is what he was
saying.
And then Stephen Hawkins came out last
week talking,
said and came out two weeks ago and said
something like,
dude,
you didn't even read it.
He didn't even read it.
And you're arguing,
you're yelling it out publicly and Stan
and that's La.
That's my point.
That was Los Angeles.
Think about anything.
Just argue it.
Not only did he argue it,
he yelled it out and I don't even know
what I was talking about.
I forgot because it was so ridiculous
what he said,
but he yelled it out like from the side
of the stage,
like it was like an important point for
him.
Did you have a conversation with them
about it?
Very little.
I talked to him a little bit from the
stage.
I tried to be nice and just segwayed
into the rest of the show,
but he just like wanted to.
It was a weird thing.
It was like he was a guy that just
wanted to argue like it wasn't a game
like he wanted to play catch with me.
Have you noticed a lot more heckling joe
lately?
No.
No,
not lately.
It's comes and goes as cool crowds and
not so cool crowds and it's always.
The crowds were always cool.
There's just always a few douchebags,
a tiny few amount of Douche bags,
but that's all you need.
You know,
if you have 300 people in a,
in a comedy club,
all you need is three Douche bags and
you've got an issue.
You have to deal one douche bag and you
got an issue.
So some you like that or I would way
rather have just a fun show.
Like in India it's stressful and started
yelling.
I did two in Indianapolis
last Friday.
Never been to Indianapolis for comedy
before.
It was fucking great,
man.
The crowds were super cool.
Dude.
Everybody's super friendly and fun.
It's a nice like easy going place and
it's a decent sized city.
It's a million,
4 million,
400,000
people.
So it's a,
it's not a small town and just really
fucking cool,
friendly people,
you know,
I like that man.
I don't want to deal with some fucking
Douche bags and need attention.
That's annoying man.
It's like I want to tell you man,
I want to pull them aside and you know,
take them away from everybody and go,
dude,
get your shit together man.
You see what you're doing.
You're out of control.
You just,
you're so needy for attention that
you're blended.
Disrupt everything around you.
I've started to notice them before they
even say anything and we often sit right
at the front,
right?
Of course,
sit right there where everyone could see
them and they're sort of these,
you can tell that these sort of,
you know,
Alpha personality types who just want
everybody to look at them.
I mean,
come on,
what,
what their problem.
No,
no,
but I mean,
you know,
the weirdest thing when people talk back
to,
you know,
if you want to do,
if you want to,
why don't you just go do comedy,
you know,
and go do your own show,
you know?
No,
they don't want to criticize.
It's like critics.
These critics hated your fucking movie.
Go make a better movie where they're not
going to make a better movie.
They have nothing to contribute.
They're contributing.
They're doing their best to be verbose
and their bitchiness that's what their
contribution is.
Be County about things.
Always look for the negative,
love everything foreign.
I mean that's really what it is,
but it's also even when the yellow fun
stuff,
it's sort of annoying too,
right?
Well,
they were saying was when think they're
trying to help you or something worse is
when they talk to you,
you ever have people in the front row
and they just talk at you,
like why would you do that?
Like,
what the fuck I'm going to get to it and
we get to the whole subject,
you know,
don't,
don't move me in a different direction.
Come on,
man.
What?
Well,
where were you going?
Why are you talking to me?
Man,
this isn't a conversation,
so fucking comedy show.
I always give people the opportunity to
yell shit out though.
I do a q and a.
It almost end of almost every one of my
shows just because it's fun.
Sometimes it's anticlimactic.
It's dangerous because sometimes it
drags on and I do the q and a for like
an hour or something.
I don't know how to end because it's so
open ended,
but I think people like fucking around
and being able to talk to me so I let
them know like,
well there'll be a time where we can
yell shit out,
but it's not.
Let me get my material.
I don't do all this and then we'll fuck
around.
Yeah,
that's a good idea.
because it's the best is when there's
lines and microphones.
That's how I did it when I recorded my
DVD.
That's the best way to do it.
A lot.
We have a line and people come up to the
line and they get to the microphone.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Because when they just yell shit out,
it just gets too crazy.
Right,
right.
Brian,
I was just going to say,
let's see guys name,
like,
you know,
look,
talk about Jews to churches in the
church.
What should he have done different now?
Because you have stuff out on,
headed on tv or you do people the Leo to
do bits that I can't remember.
A lot of them though.
The problem is when I stopped doing a
bit,
man,
I don't remember how to do it.
Like somebody yelled out,
do the talking dog that the other day,
the drug commercial bed.
And I was like fuck,
how does that go?
Like I haven't done it in a long time so
I had to try to perform it from memory.
You know,
I just,
I,
I always try to come up with new shit
and when you have new shit you got to
abandon the old shit.
You can't keep remembering it every now
and then what will pop up from like the
old days?
I remember one like,
wow,
I remember how this one goes,
but in order to keep writing new
material,
you know I've had right now I had the
first one was I'm going to dead some day
and then there was the showtime special
that I did or not,
and then there was belly of the beast
and the showtime special in 2005 and
then shiny,
happy Jihad and then talking Mikey's in
space.
That's a lot of different material.
I can't remember all that shit.
Just pop in the DVD and watch.
Watch your show.
Nobody's gonna get it back in your head
for me to watch the stuff that I've just
done recently,
it's really uncomfortable for me to
watch something like from like a few
years ago while you fucking a fleshlight
might help.
Wow.
What are you saying?
Yeah,
well,
and it's like when you were playing that
song earlier,
I was sort of sitting there kind of sort
of curling up inside my shoes,
you know,
because it's like you're looking at
something from 20 years ago and you're
gone.
I wouldn't really do it exactly that
way.
I know which way I'm patrolling,
so look truck,
do you know,
it's,
that's kind of cheesy,
but it's capturing.
Somebody said this to me once that you
know,
you just have to think of all these
performances as capturing a moment in
time,
you know,
but I,
I don't know.
That's all well and good and I
appreciate that,
but I don't want to.
It's still me,
you know,
I don't really want to watch me from 15
years ago do comedy.
It's not fun.
I don't know like me for five years ago
doing it,
you know,
it's hard watching yourself,
man,
when,
when you're,
you're very critical and honest,
you know,
it's hard.
It's hard.
Like in trying to figure out how much of
this should I be trying to enjoy this
but trying to enjoy it like a spectator
or should I be hypercritical of
everything I'm doing because that's what
I always wind up doing.
Yeah.
I'd prefer not watching myself,
but you have to go over material I think
to um,
to uh,
like you listen to bits and sometimes
you go out,
your brain will take you down different
paths.
Like go,
oh,
why didn't I say this or why didn't I
talk about that?
Or you remember like certain taglines
that you may have adlibbed at the
moment,
which may be gone if you don't remember
him.
There's a lot of my best taglines.
I forget them.
I just stopped doing it for some reason
and then I forget it and then some.
So someone will say to you like,
why don't you say that anymore?
I'm like,
Oh fuck,
I forgot.
I know you have it all written down
somewhere or most of it.
Yeah.
Most of the material is written down.
It's all written by the way I start off,
almost all of my bits is I start them
off with like blog entries.
Whether or not it gets posted on the
Internet at all.
Almost all of it is just me dissecting a
subject.
This is the method that I've come to
over the last few years is the most.
To me it's the best method because it
allows me to really examine all the
different ways I think about a subject
without worrying about people's
attention spans.
Right.
Just right.
You know,
and it could be page after page after
page,
just ramblings on what I think about
anything and then I dissect what's funny
about it,
like this is funny,
this is funny,
this is funny.
And then I say,
well how much this would go into a bit,
could this be a bit,
okay,
this could be a bat right here.
This,
this is how I'd have to say it.
And then I looked at it like that.
Like I'm stealing from myself,
I'm stealing,
get back to the Internet,
right?
People
if I post it,
but there's a lot
stuff that I read that I don't post,
stuff that I write,
I write it as if it was going to be a
blog entry and then just winds up going
into file because I don't like where I
was going with it or it wasn't finished
with it.
But I do like this part and that part
will become a bit.
Do you like,
do you think of your ideas when you sit
down to write or is it when you're out
in a boat with friends hanging out and
then you bolt?
It's everything.
I think you know,
you get different kinds of creativity
just from driving in your car with the
music off.
You know,
if you have your stereo off and you'd
just drive your car and don't talk to
anybody,
just doing that,
doing like every average everyday
things,
a percentage of your brain,
you know you're going to focus on what
you're doing and focus on our activity,
but you're going to get bored.
Your brain is going to get bored with
just driving,
so your brain is gonna.
Start thinking about things,
so percentage of your brain will start
coming up with ideas and you start
pondering things and questioning
relationships,
and you start breaking down your life
while you're driving.
No Stereo on.
Now when you got the music on,
you listen to that and then you're.
You're often no thinking land,
you know,
that's the one.
One of the most dangerous things about
the media is the fact that it's so
pervasive and it's so easy to get to and
it's so easy to just sit there and watch
and just get sucked into it and never
think at all.
I know I've been.
I've been addicted to the 24 hour news
cycle in this last few years and it just
drives me nuts.
Is the day.
Do you watch?
Oh,
well it's just on in the background.
So it's like I'm at the computer but
it's on,
in the background.
Can you sleep to news?
Uh,
no.
No.
He sleeps till dead TV at all.
No,
I don't.
Fuck all that.
That's a sickness.
Is that getting real sleep?
Sounds a little.
No.
I always do the 40 minutes.
Snipper everybody.
I know that they watch TV.
It was button on your TV.
That's cool.
And a timer.
I mean.
Really?
Yeah.
That's cool.
You do a 40 minute snooze,
40 minutes.
What do you watch?
Late night television cartoons.
Cartoon network.
So you're not sleeping while the TV's on
TV shuts itself off.
That's sort of different.
I mean I have watched TV before I go to
bed,
but I thought you were just sleeping
with the television and you don't give a
fuck.
Tom and Jerry's are lagging like no rem
sleep.
He's like barely.
Barely dream it.
Listening to books on tape.
Yeah.
You got to trick.
You have to constantly trick your mind
and you're four years old.
I woke up this morning and I have the
weirdest flight ones because I bought
this cd on the laws of attraction.
This,
uh,
this crazy woman who claims to be
channeling some,
some,
you know,
the secret or what?
No,
it was another one that was the laws of
attraction.
I forget her name,
but anyway,
she talks in this strange way,
like when she's channeling this like
Super Dad.
Oh,
Blonde Lady,
right?
You know,
when it's on Itunes,
I'll tell you princess somebody or
something.
I've seen that somewhere because,
uh,
yeah,
someone showed me that one.
So I like that,
you know,
that speaks of.
I read the secret and I found it,
found it to something that I enjoyed.
So there's this woman in panels,
this
for a deity called Abraham fell asleep,
bloods.
I listened to everything.
I have a very open mind and even if I
think someone,
it sounds crazy,
you're channeling something,
okay,
maybe you are crazy,
but maybe in your crazy,
in actual true belief,
you may have it.
So you're communicating with his deity.
Maybe you can bypass some of the
pitfalls and roadblocks and human
consciousness and maybe you could see
things that other people can truly see.
So maybe you are crazy.
Maybe you are full of shit,
but maybe you still have some good
points.
I'm willing to let that be a
possibility.
So I listen to 90 people do all kinds of
different conversations and all kinds of
different lectures and so I was
listening to this and I fell asleep
listening to it so it was on the plane
for like a five hour flight and it's
like hours and hours of lectures of this
woman talking through this man
channeling wow.
Telling you love life is loving all this
nutty fucking new age type shit.
She's channeling for this deity and the
strange voice.
She's a inflecting sorry w I landed just
thinking like I'm fucking Harry Potter
movies.
Is it have fucking program something in
your brain.
You're going to be the government
license tank and next thing you know
you're going to be like,
what was that movie with Denzel
Washington Sundry?
Made spotless mind or so?
You've reprogrammed yourself.
Totally wasn't moving something,
man.
Denzel Washington movie running,
No,
no,
fuck mean.
I'm at Man on a Shannon the fuck.
He's a security guard.
There was a security for the girl and
she gets kidnapped and have been
program.
He was programmed when he was fucking
terminator trying to help anymore.
Man.
How dare you duck.
I'm now going to get it,
man.
It was a movie where they brainwashed
him when he was younger and then they
activated him.
Oh yeah.
No,
no.
Fuck you man.
I'm the other one where the guy,
they tried to get the guys a little kid.
You dickhead fucking Dick.
That's not Denzel Washington.
Let's Macaulay Culkin.
Same Guy.
I hate not being able to remember shit.
So annoying.
Yeah.
Is there a memory supplement?
Has anybody ever taken a memory
supplement?
I mean,
what's good?
Is that real?
Because I had heard it was bullshit.
I heard Gingko was bullshitting.
If you haven't started yet,
cool.
What?
What milligrams?
I don't remember.
Can I get to talk about this off air you
had?
Do you feel that you find,
you forget things as you get older,
you forget things because you have too
much information.
I mean,
I don't feel like,
uh,
I don't recall at this point,
but yeah.
You know what I do you,
I do notice that there is a,
some sort of a scientific theory about
the amount of people that we can store
in our brain and I absolutely believe
that they say it's 150 people have room
for 150 faces and names they recognize.
I have recognized someone that I didn't
know was still in my database where you
have to re assimilate the memory and you
go,
oh,
that's a weird thing man.
It's like your brain is going,
oh well we've got a dust this off.
Hold on.
We have it.
Which way?
Back here.
So we're back here.
And then the dudes given me information.
Do you remember,
man,
we used to play pool together and white
plains.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
And then I'm going way back here.
Okay.
I got the file.
I've got the.
Because you,
you know,
this year traveling,
I've been traveling around this year
meeting,
you know,
thousands of people,
hundreds of people every weekend and
different cities.
Right?
So you're meeting all these different
people.
Do you find then you start having that
happen more where you don't when you
come back to la?
I mean especially if you like,
if you meet someone who's interesting
and you wind up talking to this dude and
you know,
you talked to him on the Internet,
well that's an internet.
You've got an internet memory now you
know this guy is a part of your Internet
group.
You know,
if you email me,
I'll my message board people sign up for
my message board and sometimes there's
some cool people have some interesting
things and what can you.
Now that guy's a nickname in my.
My things have names of people that I
can store in my mind.
I mean there's like 150.
That's where they say,
I really do find it really is.
It doesn't seem like a data issue.
It seems like a data processing issue.
It's like we're not supposed to have
access.
This may fucking people like our
hardware is not set up for this.
It's like we're trying to run quake for
a 1982 fucking pc,
you know,
that's what it is.
We're going to have to get little,
you know,
32 gigabyte chips that we can sort of
plug in behind her ear or something like
that.
You imagined just for names and phone
numbers,
if they could figure out how to update
the database of your mind,
it might have just download stuff into
your little.
Well that'll be out there soon.
It's got to be.
If you can think it,
if you can think of.
They're gonna.
They're gonna get there as long as they
keep tampering and they always will.
I'm,
that's what people do.
We keep trying to figure out what's the
coolest,
best shit and they're going to learn.
They're gonna.
Learn from it.
As long as we don't blow ourselves off
the face of the earth.
We got some petty shit coming from
nobody.
Shit.
Yeah,
it's,
um,
they're developing skin that can feel.
That's artificial.
Really.
Yes.
Artificial skin that you can feel with
their have artificial limb.
What do you mean?
What are you gonna be able to look.
You attach it to your finger and you can
make your finger like 40 feet long and
you can touch stuff eventually.
Ultimately they want you to be able to
be sensitive,
like you can pick up a piece of paper
with it or you could hold a thick mug.
Oh really?
Be able to touch and feel things.
You're going to get electrical impulses
from this artificial hands so they can
just go into your nerve endings and
they're gonna figure out how to make it
so your brain thinks this is a hand,
so they figured out the conversion of
their work to like.
I mean,
I don't know how long it is or how close
it is,
but I know that this is an ultimate
goal.
They're trying to figure out a what
would be some uses for that.
You know about fake humans,
how they gonna make fake people do
depending flashlight.
That's the real thing that are flushed
with thing is artificial life.
That's the real thing.
That's really,
really possible.
It's really possible we don't know what,
uh,
what life really is.
You know,
technology might be life,
it might be life in some sort of an
embryotic form and it has to break out
of this like a caterpillar that becomes
a butterfly.
This might with we're,
we're seeing what technology that people
created today in 2010.
We might be seeing just the,
you know,
just this egg shell that's about to
break and this new thing is going to
hatch out of it.
I A guy,
I could use a,
you know,
a,
a robot around the house that had
sensitive skin,
smooth mouth pretty lit.
So that would be so strange.
We just had this really
super hot robot that you could fuck
whenever you wanted and you didn't have
to feed her,
you could shut her off,
you can do whatever you wanted when you
turned around and was like,
oh,
we fucking up.
Clearly this is possible.
Clearly these scientists are,
are putting their,
uh,
who is going to the energy in the right
place,
tolerate their wife's bullshit.
When you can fuck this super hot robot
porn star.
Probably be something annoying and
gross.
Change your filter,
you know,
that would be a load out of her snatch.
That wouldn't be a good job.
What if she's absolutely artificial?
Even her,
you know,
her hormones are everything.
What if it literally is like an
artificial person,
you know,
but doesn't age.
She blames her own filter.
Yeah.
Queens around pussy.
Fuck yeah.
She cleans her own filter.
Hey,
why don't you just clean your own filter
already.
There's a problem.
Can you clean my filter?
And why don't you put it in your own
filter.
You embarrassed all the time.
There was already problems with that.
If you could actually have these totally
controllable artificial people where you
could program in their personality,
make them super accepting and docile and
always,
you know,
always kind and sweet and affection to
you.
What would people even get in
relationships anymore?
Would do a dudes God touches.
If you're an ugly fat guy,
you can just buy the super,
super,
insanely hot chick that's fake.
I think.
Go to movies with her and Shit.
She'll go to the movies with you.
No,
no.
That's the end.
We didn't even know he wouldn't even
know if it was a real person,
but at the end,
and they'll be like some old fat fucked
up dude with no teach shit all over his
clothes.
She doesn't care.
She's a robot.
She's hot as fuck.
She looks like traci lords in her prime
and they're holding hands at the movie
theater.
People getting pissed off.
Fucking real woman.
Except the way you would know a little
bit the way you would know is because
when it first happens,
there'd only be five models.
You know,
there'd be the blonde,
you know,
there'd be the Burnett,
so you'd see them again.
You're like smart cars going around or
whatever and they'll do anything.
They'll suck your dick and a taxi cab.
They don't give a fuck the robot and
people are going to go off.
It's gonna be crazy.
Debit probably have like dead eyes.
You know when you look in somebodies
eyes,
you tell maybe,
maybe the puppy dog eyes,
maybe the crush.
You maybe fall in love with that robot
and you're trying to figure out a way to
breed with her had puppies and that's.
Maybe that's the apocalypse.
We do figure out a way to breed,
but can you tell me a little bit about
this flashlight since we're on the topic
of,
of having sex with.
It's a thing that you really.
It is.
Fuck this one.
I think some of the other part.
This is.
This is your sponsor,
your show.
Yes.
Manufacturer believe Austin,
Texas.
That's where the company's located.
He hung out with that group of companies
can get in there.
That'd be good.
I'll turn it for me.
Don't really feel like touching.
I should feel it.
You should feel like no one is lax with
this.
Yes.
This is just a sample that they sent us.
Just trust it.
Okay.
All right.
Yep.
You're pretty good,
right?
That the finger and I'm not going to put
my finger.
No,
no.
It feels like it.
Just feel it.
I can imagine.
Might have a very imagination
that is.
That's interesting.
Better than the cow.
Now let me ask you this.
I don't have to ask you whether or not
you masturbate because of course you do,
but I.
But would you be willing to buy a
masturbation tool that would make
masturbation better?
Probably not.
Right then you have to sort of as open
does get a free one.
Because I was like,
yeah,
I wouldn't.
Would I be willing to find that one
left?
Hold on.
I'm just kidding.
Actually.
Well,
you know,
might be fun just for conversation at
parties or something like that.
Hey know I've got.
I'll give it to you.
I'll go find it.
It's in here somewhere.
Yeah.
No,
I mean you don't know what kind of porn
is Tom Greenlight do?
You definitely would have to be in a
sealed rapper.
Let's put it as a common.
A seals.
Hermetically sealed plastic.
Absolutely.
Insurance.
I would not advise you to fuck that.
Yeah.
You don't want Brian Cowen touch that.
This has been in touch.
This has been unsealed.
Is it a signature thing?
I think Ricky Schroder even touched that
one.
Did Ricky Schroder test?
Ricky Schroder touched.
And so does it do anything?
Does it vibrate or anything?
So you don't need that?
No,
it's just a.
it's just that's what it is.
Just that you know what it is,
man,
it just makes it way better feeling than
your hand and you're not getting any.
You're not getting any signal from it.
It's patented rubber.
You know,
they have their own patent on how it
really feels great America made in the
USA.
Very interesting thing.
These fish in a bucket.
Look at that.
That's what he calls it.
Fill out.
This is what it's called.
This is called deer in a tree.
He just making up names.
It's not what it's called.
It's a great product for,
for 60 bucks or whatever it costs.
It's totally worth it.
It makes beating off way more fun.
What kind of porn do you like?
Why are you an amateur guy or take off,
take your pants off when you asked that
question.
You know,
I don't even know anymore,
man.
It's gotten so crazy out there.
Magazine kids today are not so crazy.
Well,
what's gotten crazy man?
I think basically just the sort of
instant access to anything online.
It's kind of starting actually to get to
the point where,
um,
you know,
it's not as an amazing thing.
Porn,
you know,
I was,
when,
when we were kids,
you know,
when we were,
when we were like,
you know,
when I was,
when I was a kid,
they didn't have that obviously,
so you'd be excited when,
you know,
like when a sears catalog comes,
you'd be excited,
you know,
this is,
this is what you would,
uh,
you know,
there was not this access to it.
So to,
it's,
it's almost like overwhelming to me now.
I think I've watched too much of it in
my life and I'm not interested in not
much anymore,
you know,
to be honest with you when you're
campaigning for a nice curl.
When I start,
when I started seeing it online and
video,
to be honest with you,
I've watched it a lot because I was
interesting in the web streaming
technology.
Yeah.
So I would go on some of the sites just
to kind
of cuts it just for purely
technological.
It was sort of like a business or
research kind of thing.
Because I'm doing my web show,
I want to see that the streaming quality
was good and things like,
and you can get the most data from the
facial section.
That's what I find.
Yeah.
But uh,
but uh,
it's,
I,
I think that's what's going to happen to
us.
Are we going to go,
are we all going to go crazy because of
this porn everywhere and these people
fucking,
they're just going crazy because they'd
been suppressed for so long until
everybody comes down and then they're
going to realize that,
well,
I don't really like watching all this
crazy mouth fucking until tools throw up
and coming in their eyeballs know shit.
I don't really like that.
You go back to making love videos,
they're actually better than the porn
fucking video.
Oh,
I've never heard of that.
Bull in really in love.
And they just sit there and make love.
It's really pretty nice.
This is a better way.
Some fetish site.
You're into it.
You don't even like professionals,
boy and like fucking scabs.
The love videos highlighting the porn
union.
Very nice.
Oh,
and where do you find that?
Google love making love videos.
The website,
I've never heard of this one chick
that's like the most famous blowjob
artists in all of the world.
I don't remember her name,
but she's really feeling it was.
But she,
uh,
it's,
I,
uh,
I deep throat.com.
Heather,
that's her name is heather.
Heather something on and she's got like,
I dunno,
100 fucking videos and they're all of
her blowing.
Her husband blown this dude everywhere.
And she has the most ridiculous lack of
gag reflexes.
She's got none.
So if he's got a big tank,
she's down to the balls,
look in his balls every time.
Does nothing for me.
They have,
they have,
they have videos all over the place on
the Internet,
like he's turned his wife sucking his
dick and to like a website.
That's an interesting way to go.
Do you like it more if you'd like more
violent videos?
I don't like it.
Well,
I like her.
She's not doing it violent.
She's not throwing up something.
I know that she can just do without
gagging.
That's the crazy thing.
The other ones,
like there's a lot of sasha great porn
that fucking hard to watch.
That chickens are a mile away.
You did the first,
uh,
watching two girls,
one cup video,
right?
Did you do that?
It wasn't the first.
Oh No,
we did.
It was watching.
It was.
The shot was on the reactions.
What was that called?
What's that called when?
The reaction reaction?
Video video.
That was one of those.
It was good one for reaction videos
because everybody knew by the sound of
the music what was going on if you'd
already seen it.
That was a very odd sort of blip on the
pop culture radar the day that that came
out,
right?
Yeah.
And there was this site dedicated to one
video and everybody went and watched a
couple of days,
got millions and millions and millions
of views.
I joke about it and I bring it up on
stage sometimes and it's incredible how
many people have seen it.
And I think what's interesting about it
is it repulsed people so instantly that
it didn't really catch on like it did.
That hasn't since has it
where there's been one domain name comes
out,
you know,
three girls more.
Whatever you guys want to.
There's nothing written.
Two guys went,
horse guy gets fucked to death by a
horse.
Oh,
I've heard about that in Seattle and he
had to change the law.
Five hands.
One girl was another one.
Oh Jesus Christ.
There was a guy,
I think I've told this story before,
but I'll tell you he made that up
because you're hearing.
That's what I'm saying.
The point I'm making is that I know will
take off.
It was a dude that I know who's friend
was dating
porn star and they were trying to.
He was trying to reconcile the fact that
she fucked guys and this was just a job
and blah blah,
blah blah blah.
Just kinda like put it in the back of
his head.
And um,
she came home with the contract and
she's going over the different parts of
the contract and he goes,
what's,
what's this air tight?
And she goes,
Oh,
airtight means a dick.
And every hall he goes,
what?
What am I asked?
One of my pussy,
one of my mouth.
He goes,
okay,
this is over.
That was,
that was a them airtight,
cracked up the fact that they actually
have a,
a name for it,
plugged up with Dick's.
And then what are you gonna?
Come home and cuddle after that.
Share tight.
Unbelievable.
Yeah.
And so,
and,
and what happened?
He just walked out the door and never
talked to her again.
And I was fucking.
Clinics would airtight.
Yeah,
they,
I think,
you know,
when,
when you've,
your girlfriend's got airtight and her
contract,
that's really strange
thing that a lot of the people in the
porn business do.
They figure out a way to have boyfriends
and girlfriends and be in relationships,
but they still fuck the fuck other
people when they work,
but they're only allowed to do it when
they're working.
Yeah,
it must,
it must because we're also,
uh,
you know,
accustomed to seeing it now that people
probably out there actually can justify
it in their mind because,
oh,
this is a legitimate profession here.
There's one is the Tom Green sex tape
come out when he was a pop.
Is there barrymore dealing with 100 to a
hundred different women's.
You hate the hate MACs.
What's that?
Do you hate?
What do you know?
That's something I don't think I could
ever ever see myself doing.
Is there one that exists though that you
know of?
Uh,
there's not,
there's definitely not one that I know
of.
You know,
you don't videotape yourself,
you know,
not regularly,
but I think it's from paranoia of A.
I'm not going to say I never did it once
in my life,
but you know,
the,
the thing is,
is I immediately deleted it and was a
strong move immediately deleted.
It didn't keep it around,
you know,
uh,
honestly,
you know,
I didn't even really,
really want to watch it to be honest
with you.
You loved it.
Yeah.
It was fun.
The process of videotape,
you don't want to watch it though.
Not really.
No.
It was kind of freaked me out when I do
it.
I'm just so disgusted.
It depresses me in the body,
but I do have one.
Well,
what depresses you?
Huh?
What depresses me?
It's just A.
I don't know.
Watching yourself as grown.
Like,
wait a minute,
Brian,
stop right now.
Listen to how you're advertising your
sex.
You're a single man and you're saying
you have depressing.
I mean,
would you,
do you like watching yourself?
Like do you masturbate and it like.
I mean,
do you masturbate with looking at
yourself in the mirror?
Why would you want to watch yourself
watching yourself having sex and you try
to recreate a life.
Wipe yourself on news radio.
Why would you having sex?
It doesn't depress me.
God.
No,
I just don't like watching myself have
sex.
Okay,
I see.
I totally.
I totally see what you're saying.
It's disturbing.
What about if you do pov style,
that would be cool.
That would be slapping iphone.
Do you checks?
That would be foreign press record.
Slap an iphone.
Do Charge capture as what did you do?
Have one with me of when I was like 16
or 17,
you know,
using my dad's vhs camera that would
make like old home movies about carrots
attack me and Steph and I would like set
it up in my room and stuff and I have
one of like,
but then I look at it and like,
can I get in trouble for watching
myself?
You know,
your child pornography with yourself.
Well,
could I get for myself their girlfriend?
Yeah.
Yeah,
probably.
Right.
I should just throw that tape right.
Well you got get arrested.
Probably if you could be public,
could be illegal master patient.
It could be considered a child
pornography to catch kids for 16 years
old.
Could you be charged for being in
possession of child pornography?
Is that kids are getting their cell
phones taken away and they find photos
of them.
Girls are getting charged with child
pornography because they have a photo of
themselves for themselves that they sent
to him.
Boy,
they're charged with child pornography.
So you probably should destroy that
tape.
White tape.
Well that's like the,
you know the old tape,
isn't it?
To allegedly had a to B,
how many gay guys are frantically
searching the internet for a video of
Brian at 15 masturbating.
Not a nice thought.
No,
not for me personally,
but you know,
but the,
the,
uh,
the um,
podcast.
Tom Green.
No.
So wait,
what was the,
what was the thing then?
So,
uh,
um,
yeah,
and it was let's change.
Let's change the topic,
right?
Sex tapes is marijuana.
Yeah.
And you know what the subject was
getting depressed.
Watching yourself.
Fuck.
Yup.
And that he should do pov style.
I love it.
When your song was released and then w
was destroying the charts for Tlc and
then you gay,
you trl,
trl.
And then did you,
were you forced to get rid of?
Guess I was forced to for 98 degrees.
That whole thing was,
it's a very,
um,
uh,
you know,
there's a,
there's a little bit of intrigue here
behind the story because there was,
you know,
some,
some things done trl that were not
necessarily ever made public.
Right.
Okay.
Well fill me full detail.
What happened?
What happened,
like the to the,
and trl isn't necessarily,
it's not necessarily live and all the
time,
so it's not on anymore.
Nobody knows the song.
What was the song and what happened?
Okay.
So we went to Seattle and we were
filming bits and Seattle and we thought,
hey,
this would be funny to do the song
called the bum bumps on it.
My favorite songs,
ridiculous idea.
And I would go and it was just a silly
video.
Me going around Seattle saying Obama's
on the cheese,
my bum's on the rail albums in the boat.
My bumps on the duck.
It was a silly sort of like a doctor zoo
style nursery rhyme,
rap and,
and the,
and the comedy of it was me out in the
street sticking my ass on everything and
confusing people and filming the
reactions.
Right.
And singing this silly song.
And then we played it on my show and we
said we want this to go to number one on
total request live,
which is,
you know,
their countdown music show that they
would have every night hosted by Carson
Daly.
And I'm.
So we played it on Seattle radio and it
went to number one.
Instantly.
This was when my show was on MTV.
It was,
it was really doing well.
Show on MTV show was doing well on MTV.
People went to number one,
people saw the absurdity of this song
knocking 98 degrees,
Brittany Spears in sync and whoever else
was on the j Lo,
I think out of the,
out of the number one spot.
And so we went.
We played it on the show,
we asked people to vote for it,
people voted for it.
It went to number one on Tuesday.
Okay.
The show I think aired on a Monday.
It went to number one on a Tuesday.
This is the song.
Yeah.
My mom like fucking a huge.
This song was.
And this was the first song to be like,
this was right when mp three s just
started.
So it was the number one downloaded song
that year.
I thought you.
I think 14 people downloaded it.
It was a.
It was.
No,
no,
this was 1999 to 2009.
So what happened?
So they squashed your song?
Yeah,
it went to number one on Tuesday,
then on Wednesday on Wednesday it was
number one,
number one again.
Okay.
And then on Thursday it was number one
again and then we get a call on Thursday
at the office and they're saying,
guys,
we want you to kind of play ball with us
here.
And we're like,
well what's the deal?
He said,
well,
you know,
we need,
we need you to go on the show on Friday
and retire the bum bum song and take it
off the countdown.
And we're like,
why?
It's the number one song in America on
TV,
man.
Yeah,
right.
Is Amazing.
Right?
Money off this.
This is unbelievable.
Let's keep it number one.
They go,
well the thing is we've pre taped the
show next week because Carson's going to
be in San Francisco and all this stuff.
So we're Kinda,
it's Kinda like who we think's going to
be and we hadn't predicted you erin the
show on Monday and it instantly going to
number one,
so it kind of screws up next week's
pre-taped,
which is all in the can.
So can you go on on a Friday and just
retire it and we'll give you like a
retirement home plaque and here I was on
MTV and I had my show on MTV and I
didn't want to get fired.
Right.
Everybody's already mad at me about all
this other shit screaming at me all day
about,
you know,
I want to suck milk out of cows better
because I think it'll be crazy.
Let's put it on TV.
And they're like,
can't you can't do that.
We're arguing nonstop.
It was like,
it was the most stressful time of my
life and that's saying something because
I'm pretty stressed out right now to,
not right now,
but most of the time,
you know,
and so,
so I'm on the show and I'm getting
yelled at all the time by everybody.
Everyone's always screaming at each
other,
trying to know,
make the show crazy
or make it less crazy.
And then so,
you know,
I played ball,
I went in,
I got a nice plaque and you know what?
I'm not even to be honest with you.
Not Well,
yeah.
You know,
I think of it now.
I think,
you know,
we could have rode that thing a little
further.
I could have put out a record.
I probably could have know had some fun
with that.
But um,
yeah,
that's what happened.
That's what happened.
That's,
that's interesting man.
That's fucked.
You're fucked by the corporations.
Yeah,
exactly.
It was a sense that they would probably
cost them a fuck load of money in
theater already.
Pre-Taped reshoot five shows and it's
like,
how crazy is that?
Now you find out what the rankings are
like.
It's totally,
they prop them up.
It probably had deals with the record
company,
like we need to push 98 degrees and
here's $100,000
we need to probably it's illegal.
I mean that's definitely did that.
They did that.
I never heard any.
Just making shit up.
No,
no.
I'm just throwing shit on the table.
I never did anything like that.
I think it was just basically it was a
very strange week and uh,
they,
they sort of said it wasn't for that
week.
That song could have stayed on the
countdown and because I can't.
Basically that week was a Republican
Republic of the week before and what are
you doing Brian?
To be screaming.
They ended the song.
Was that video going out to and that's
an Ipad,
which is pretty awesome,
but it's actually just streaming on the
ipad but it's not going out.
That's pretty cool.
People can hear the audio audio but you
know,
I've,
I've told that story before.
I don't think anyone at MTV cares
anymore.
It's on.
Well,
why would they care?
Fuck you.
You're the one supposed to care.
You could have got paid.
So driving that fucking song right now
in the form of a Red Ferrari.
Yeah,
that's true.
I'm saying it could be rolling with a
big fat diamond encrusted watch.
Let bitches know and they'd be like,
Tom Green,
how'd you get?
So rich bum,
bum,
bum bum song was on.
Try to pull it off the an into eminem
song.
It's just try to pull it off the end.
I was like a song on song and oh you
know those same song when eminem rapped
about an m and m wrap.
M and m took the line from the bung
bumps on.
He says,
why can't I go on TV and let loose when
it's cool for Tom Green to hump a dead
Moose?
My bum is on your lips,
but bumpers on your lips and if you get
lucky I'll give it a little kiss that
seven.
I'm doing that.
And the thing that's funny about that,
which is really cool,
is that like,
you know that song,
it's like I hear that all over the
world.
It says your name in it,
right?
So you're walking through something,
you're walking through an airport in
Amsterdam or something and it's like,
you know,
you hear him rapping about it.
It's pretty cool.
Who would've thought that m and M would
have?
I mean I guess it was pretty awesome and
it came up,
but I mean just to be around.
I have not met him.
No,
but he let us use that song and Freddy
got fingered through.
You know,
we had to license it but he doesn't
license music out that much.
He gives a sweet deal.
We've got to put it in the credit roll
of Freddy got fingered.
So that was pretty cool.
Thank you.
That is awesome.
Very cool.
Marshall mathers.
You know,
that's pretty cool.
Do you still write music?
Do you have to think about doing another
hits?
You don't have
a friend of mine who is a really cool
producer here in town who uh,
who,
uh,
I make music with sometimes the names
detail and he does a lot of cool music
and uh,
I just do it for fun.
I have a home studio for fun.
You got to the pro tools and the MAC
computer and he's cool.
Yeah.
So you got your fingers in all aspects
of show business.
You're always doing something more like
a hobby,
you know,
it's more just a fun thing,
but it's a fun thing.
You know,
the songs I make are so ridiculous that
they're never,
I don't think I'm really there ever
would be sort of any mainstream.
So I think the standup thing is an
interesting subject because you didn't
do standup for a long time.
You did stand up when you were like 15,
16 and then you stopped for like God,
what?
Twenty years?
Uh Huh.
I would do it sort of occasionally but
never sort of as I had an act that I was
working on.
Launched it.
What made you decide to want to get back
into it?
Uh,
you know about a,
a boot boot.
Yeah,
I do.
That still has the one that's the one
word that I get nailed on gifts.
Sear goes sincere.
You go deep detail.
Canadian beer,
a boat.
Uh,
you know,
I do when I can do what I can,
I just sort of drink a drink when I can.
And so what happened?
So,
uh,
well about two years ago,
Rob Schneider came on my show as a guest
on the web show and uh,
his brother John also came up and
started hanging out with those guys and
it was maybe about a year and a half
ago,
John said,
he know rob's doing stand up now too.
He's been touring all year and he said,
rob's gonna start doing stand up.
You should start doing standup.
And I thought,
you know,
this would be pretty cool way.
First of all,
it's something that I've been thinking
about since I was a kid and I was very
intimidated by it.
I was afraid of it.
It was in the back of my head.
I was kind of thinking,
you know,
I don't know,
just,
you know,
I was so used to doing the show and I
remember how hard it was when I was a
teenager,
you know,
when you're 15 years old,
standing up in front of a bunch of
college kids,
you know,
it's,
it was,
it was tough.
Things were stressful thing.
So I've done it over the years,
hosting shows and things like this in
front of the audience,
but not having the act.
Rob was doing it.
He was going around jumping up at clubs
around town,
at the Ice House in Pasadena and to the
belly room at the comedy store.
And,
and,
uh,
we just kind of going around and trying
out stuff and it sort of instantly was,
you know,
instantly was something that I
immediately was kind of.
I thought Jesus,
you know,
why did I not start doing this sooner?
This is just such a great thing.
You know,
part of it also is I've been living in
La for 10 years.
I got this web studio in my house,
you know,
Kinda thinking,
I got to get out of the house sometime
here in la.
I need something social to do that's not
going to sit in some loud nightclub
drinking with people.
You know,
what,
Hey,
this is something that really kind of
wrap my hands around.
I also was missing getting up in front
of an audience,
you know,
the radio,
the web show is in the living room so
you don't have the audience.
So it's just been,
it's been an amazing time.
And,
and uh,
you know,
basically did it for about six months
and in La just jumping up and writing,
writing,
lots of stuff.
And uh,
I've,
I've off,
I've been here,
I've got to go to Australia for the
first time,
but you're doing like an hour onstage
and it went down.
Is Very few people have ever gone from,
I don't do standup too.
I'm headlining on the road performing on
stage for an hour.
That's a pretty incredible.
When you used to have to actually go
about an hour and 15 when you used to do
stand up,
how long did you used to do like you
used to do a long,
long,
long time ago.
But no one.
I was thinking I was like do you know
at,
at its peak,
about 15 minutes.
Fifteen minutes.
Middle,
middle end.
But it was five to seven minutes opening
act and amateur night at first.
You know.
Tell me how you,
how,
how you concocted this tour.
I mean,
how many,
how long have you been doing standup
before you said,
all right,
I'm going to take this to the road now.
Basically what happened was I was
jumping up all around town and the Norm
Mcdonald asked me to open up from one
night and do some shows with him one
night just to kind of get,
you know,
keep practicing.
And then,
uh,
and uh,
essentially,
um,
I and Sarah [inaudible] from [inaudible]
who came to all my shows and said,
you know what,
I'm going to book you on a tour.
And I said,
well,
that's pretty cool.
And she now.
Okay.
How many months is this into your stent?
I've been nine months on the road and
she's been between the time you got back
on stage at the time you started.
How long was that?
Uh,
this was probably about six months or
something like that.
Crazy.
So you very much with the intention of I
want to go on the road.
And it's very impressive that you were
able to put together over an hour of
material in six months.
That's amazing,
isn't it?
You know,
I thought I was doing the same jokes
again last night.
You're developing new shit out of
nowhere.
And my friend Mike Young did some shit
that he did nine years ago last night.
You know,
I approached it from a really kind of
the way I approach doing my television
show or my web show very from very like
I would,
I would be writing all the time and
trying to build up the diligence,
jumping up to and stuff.
I organized it all out in paper and how
he.
Is that what you're doing?
Yeah.
I just don't know.
I just,
you know,
for the first,
for the first few months of doing our
set,
I had a,
I had a set list.
I actually took on stage with me and I'd
set it on the,
on the stool,
so my water on it.
I do my bits and then I'd,
if I've got lost,
I'd look down.
That's a good move.
You know Doug Benson brings a notes on
stage and goes,
look,
you don't want me to be stumbled around
wondering what the fuck I'm talking
about.
This is good.
But eventually after,
after awhile though,
I was feeling like it was kind of a bit
of a crutch because I like to.
I'm trying to be really physical.
You don't have to use it,
you know the thing.
The thing about it.
No,
I don't use no notes,
but the thing about notes,
the good thing is that they're,
you know,
if you need them,
they're there.
You know?
It's like why not have it there?
Yeah.
No,
there's sometimes you're like,
I want to hear.
Like Joey Diaz will say,
what the fuck was I talking about?
What the fuck was I talking about?
Right.
Oh,
that's it.
And you tell him and then he's got the
story and it would just run and ramble
on to the story.
Sometimes you just need a little note.
Yeah.
I think I might start putting new stuff
that I've never done before on notes and
pulling that out at some point or
setting.
There's something I can remember.
All this stuff I've done for once.
I've done it three or four times,
I can remember it,
but usually I can't remember it.
There's something about writing things
down on paper that's really
good for your memory to actually the act
of creating a note makes it solidify in
your mind and when you use your memory,
you can recall like what you wrote,
like you could see it in the order.
I just have a set list of just your
basic cool.
The iphone thing.
Setlist is cool.
That's definitely better than nothing,
but I think writing something down on
paper seems to have the most effect.
It seems to be sticks better.
Yeah.
So do you,
when you wrote out your act,
did you write out a ver,
a beginning,
a middle and an end?
Did you put it all together verbatim or
do you ad Lib when you're on stage?
Uh,
yeah.
Initially I sort of a yeah,
I ad Lib a lot on stage,
but I have this sort of pretty solid
began like I know where I'm nowhere I'm
going to start.
I know I'm going to do when I start,
I know when I'm going to do,
when I'm finished actually pretty much
know the order I'm going to go in
through the bits that I've tried and
tested and then uh,
but then often I'll kind of go off into
the audience between bits for a second
and talk to some people for a second.
And,
but uh,
but what's happened is it sort of
evolved over the year,
like last nine months of doing it is
every week I'll kind of go,
you know,
maybe this is a little too depressing,
have a subject matter to talk off the
top.
So then I'll move it sort of later in
the act.
And then it's kind of a,
it's been fun.
It's been really fun and challenging,
you know,
doing it and a sort of shuffling things
around all the time.
And so it's,
it's been cool and I write bits down in
my phone,
in my notepad,
in my phone if I think something weird
and then I'll go home and I'll type it
up in the computer.
And so do you type it up as a joke or do
you type up bullet points,
like what do you do?
I usually write it out word for word
with punchlines and exactly how I'm
going to say it and then I edit it and I
get it exactly what I want to be and
then you know,
and then I try to sort of remember it
and then usually the first time I say it
on stage,
I forget about half of the taglines,
forget about half of them and then I,
but I say it but then I get off the
stage and I immediately remember,
Oh,
I forgot that,
that,
that.
And I think the disappointment of
forgetting them makes it easier to
remember the next time because then I go
look at them again.
I go,
got to remember this tag line,
this line.
And so it's sort of,
it's interesting.
It is interesting because you really,
it really is kind of cool,
you know,
I mean again this first year of doing
this full time night after night,
but to see what people tell you,
no,
you got to get up.
It's like a muscle,
you get up on stage,
you start to pertain it differently and,
and you know,
you know,
there's been obviously periods for two,
three weeks where I haven't done a show
this year and then,
you know,
you get back on,
it's weird.
You can't remember anything
cool a week or two off all the time and
want to come back on stage.
I'm like,
I always have to do a warmup set.
I'd do something in town in La and then
it charges it and then that's the only
time.
Well that's the time where I'll go over
material just to familiarize myself with
what I've been talking about most
recently.
So I have like my iphone records all my
sense and I get recordings from Brian
too.
So then I take them and I put them on my
ipod and I just listened to my plans.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
So it makes you dissect your shit also
unconfident audio record and be better
than what you're listening to.
You know,
you want to tighten it up and this,
that Oh yeah.
That's cool.
And you're not hearing it for the first
time.
You're hearing it for the 400th time and
it's,
you know,
you really start breaking shit.
So you recorded in an ipod or
sometimes I'm the iphone.
Sometimes I feel from him.
He
plugs up.
Oh yeah.
Good idea.
That's helpful because then you can hear
the little things that you say.
So you're enjoying it,
man.
You're enjoying this whole process.
So yeah,
it's been really,
really fun.
And you know,
I like what we were talking about when,
when we were having coffee when I got
here in the kitchen,
you know,
we're talking about,
you were talking about how it's just
nice to be in an independent thing where
you know,
you want to come up with a crazy idea
and it was a funny thought and you go up
and you can try it and there's no,
you know,
somebody coming in and telling you not
to say this or do that.
That's it.
That's the most frustrating thing for
anybody.
Controversial.
Like you is got to be a bunch of
executives that have their ideas about
what they think is going to be funny and
they're imposing it and you're like,
look,
it may not be funny for you.
It might not be funny for three people
in this room,
but for people in this room,
I think it's the funny shit they've ever
seen and you're going for those four
people and these people can never see
that.
All they can see is,
but you're losing three.
You just took this back.
This person would still like it yet
still get the original people and we'd
have two more people that like it.
Yeah.
That's how they think.
They think in these nutty numbers and
they're not thinking creative
and then you end up spending most of
your time dealing with that and at the
end,
at the end of it all,
you're never really sure what it would
have been if you'd just sort of gone
wild on your own.
Beautiful,
great freedom and just being on the road
has been really fun.
It's been really fun.
It's been a good way.
I also thought it'd be cool way to go
out and film stuff for my website
because I always wanted to.
I've always said,
hey,
it'd be cool to take my web show,
you know,
and go to different cities and see the
people that watched the web show,
you know,
people call in on Tom Green.com,
they call it on skype.
I know.
Recognize every show I go to.
It's so bizarre.
You know,
every show I go to,
I recognize 10 people saying,
Hey John,
how you doing?
You know,
I've never been to the city before,
you know,
and it's like,
hey,
we gotta set up skype.
Dude,
we've got four Chan.
You scared of fortune?
Yeah.
Don't be scared.
Oh yeah,
that's fine.
That's fine.
That's just somebody to fuck with you.
Scared of them.
She never admitted.
I fucked up.
I'm not scared of you already fucked up.
You already.
Fuck.
I wanted to join them.
Now we're talking about,
you know,
the thing is,
is with the.
I mean to give you a little bit of a,
of an idea here.
Okay.
So what we've done in my eyesight,
because four Chan was,
was I,
I found,
did some fairly clever and ridiculous
and absurd prank calls on us constantly.
They are completely irrelevant and
obviously the most annoying thing
because it's completely irrelevant.
I'm sitting here with guests,
right?
So.
But that was on the phone,
but on skype it's a,
it's a much more difficult for them to
do that because we've created a system
which I'll tell you about off air
actually.
I'll tell you about off air.
Off Air.
So I motherfuckers you aint
getting to stay one step ahead.
Step ahead of the four Chan guys,
bell all system for skype that you can
actually use that will help help in that
area for Chan.
Don't do it.
Fucked up.
You heard everybody's ears and you
pissed a bunch of people off.
They're coming after you now dude.
Fucked up.
So we went after that bitch that through
puppies in the river.
They got her.
Was that loud for Cenk?
Got that.
It was all right.
Just a little annoyance.
Um.
Well Tom Bring.
I'm losing my hearing because of stuff
like that too.
Did you want me to.
I think I'm starting to lose my hearing.
I have noticed a lot of times I'm in
conversations with people and they're
talking to me as if I should be able to
hear what they're saying the same.
Same with me and I'm like thinking maybe
I'm just not paying attention to them,
but I can't hear them.
Call it.
Having your years blown out from people,
is that what it is or is it just a bunch
of people that are talking all soft
talk,
like a fucking normal person.
Some people just mumbled certain
frequencies to when people have sort of
that frequency of noisy area.
Tell me how annoying is that?
What kind of stuff do you talk about?
That is the dumbest question.
I mean,
I know it's a relevant question,
but for,
for a comic,
what?
What are you.
What are the things you're talking about
right now?
Well,
when we tell you,
I think Sarah Pailin is dumb.
Yeah,
let me do the bit right now.
Which doesn't really.
You know,
killer whales are smart.
You shouldn't be in pools are going to
run out.
You have a lot of Ufo stuff going on,
Huh?
It wasn't there and I go into a little
UFO,
but somebody.
Exactly what you're talking.
Because I think that people,
when they ask that question,
you don't understand how important the
audiences when you're telling these
things,
it's so much part of it.
So you know,
you need the audience there.
That's cool.
So wait Ufo thing,
if you have you been paying attention to
what's going on?
That's something that an appointed a
liaison or a spokesperson for the
American for,
for the human race rather in
communication.
When aliens land.
Really it's some weird looking chick.
She was like very like,
it's not Sarah Pale man looking.
She's the person that they're not to.
Don't get me wrong.
She's a strange looking.
She's the person that we're going to
talk to.
She's speaking for you.
Shouldn't we have some sort of insight?
Fuck the UN over the world.
I don't know what the pucker just like.
Is that like just like,
oh,
and if we ever get attacked by aliens,
you have.
They did this.
Maybe.
Maybe like a resident firefighter.
It's just like that's the most basic
part.
I hope so because you imagine that's a
fulltime job.
Can you imagine if she gets like 100
grand a year in benefits and all she has
to just sit around and wait for the
answer.
Call feet up.
Reading US magazine.
Yeah.
Keep up to date and what's important?
Who the fuck it looked?
The aliens don't give a fuck about who
the leader is.
They don't give a shit.
If they were going to come here from
another galaxy.
They're the leader.
There is no leader.
You don't get to represent like the
aliens don't care.
What's the fucking number one aunt you
know?
Do you ever look at who's the one aunt
before I kill
all you people.
He just killed all the answers.
There's no discussion.
Yeah.
You don't to have communication with
ants over.
You know who's going to die and whether
or not you guys can move out.
No.
You just killed them all and if that's
what aliens decide to do to us,
we'll do the same thing to us that we
do.
The monkeys that we do to dolphins that
we did a killer whales,
but they treat us well.
They should be like that monkey that was
holding the kitten the other day.
They might just come down and cradle us.
It might be the exact opposite.
They might just be like,
hey,
we just want to comb your hair and fuzzy
to Baka type creatures that come down.
Just want to.
It's.
I try to keep these thoughts,
these ideas of Ufo aliens.
I tried to keep him away from my
consciousness because I think they're
giant time-wasters contemplate what if
the aliens are really these Ufo videos
real?
I'm open.
I'm open to the possibility that there
are aliens,
but I'm not gonna.
Sit around and watch some fucking lights
in the sky that I don't know what the
fuck it is.
It turned out it was actually a
helicopter and you're actually retarded,
you know?
Oh,
you know,
I mean maybe this is.
It was a prank when those little
helicopters that he souped up and has a
couple leds and I'm not closed to the
idea that there are something there that
it is possible that there are some sort
of intelligent life forms out there that
are capable of traveling here,
whether they're from another planet or
another dimension.
It wouldn't be ridiculous,
but everything about this life would be
ridiculous.
We weren't living it.
The idea that we can get the Internet
would be ridiculous if it didn't exist.
The idea that you could send pictures
from your phone,
the idea that you had to have a phone
that fits in your pocket and you call
someone in China and to talk in real
time.
Everything is so small condensed now.
It's so much smaller now.
It's also strange that it's going to
feel entirely possible.
There's something super advanced past
this and they can communicate with us
and it's probably could be here right
now watching us,
but these guys that came out today or
that you were.
You were talking about last couple days
that are air force generals,
etc.
That have been sworn to secrecy for last
50 years or whatever that say that,
uh,
you know,
they came and checked out some nuclear,
um,
our nuclear sites and that they shut off
some nuclear weapons and they're all
saying that this happened.
Do you Think that happened?
Or it could be one of two things.
Well,
it can be many things,
but one of the things that it could be
that I was thinking is maybe these guys
are like being paid by the government to
say absolutely ridiculous things and
that nothing ever really happened at
all.
And what there are is a part of some
sort of a disinflation campaign and then
eventually turn out.
They lied about a few details and that
will discredit the whole story.
And it just makes aliens seem more and
more ridiculous to calm people down
because maybe there may be some things
that they can't keep wraps on.
And when those things are leaked,
the best way to diffuse the impact that
some,
some sort of a crazy event or video.
The best way to diffuse the impact would
be to show all these other ones have
similar stories that seem absolutely
ridiculous,
so it automatically gets lumped into,
oh,
it's a ufo video.
Oh,
you're crazy.
you believe that?
And so it automatically puts it into
that category.
I mean,
that's an effective psychological
tactic.
If you were someone like the cia or
someone in the nsa,
someone who's of a super intelligence
community,
they know how to fucking manipulate
people,
don't,
don't make no mistake about it.
They absolutely do.
So it could be that or it could be that
these people really saw some shit and
they don't even know what the fuck it
is.
It could be that you know that they're
all crazy.
there's,
there's a bunch of bs,
but until I see something,
until some shit comes into my life,
I'm just wasting my time.
I just don't want to sit around
thinking,
you know,
whether or not half this shit is real.
And rob [inaudible],
did he really work at area?
Do you want to know that guy?
I saw that guy.
I've watched all.
I got addicted to watching that stuff
for a lot,
for,
for a good year.
I was addicted to watching all this
stuff and,
and uh,
and,
and talk to this disclosure,
you know,
they're gonna get,
they're gonna tell us soon.
They're just prepping us for it,
you know,
the disclosure project.
I really do hope that,
uh,
they tell us soon because I think that
would be pretty cool,
man.
I think there's a lot of people
scrambling trying to figure out a bunch
of different things that don't make
sense and I think it's very possible
that there are some alien life forms,
but I do not think that our government
has shit under control enough to keep
all that shit under wraps and to somehow
or another be communicating with these
things.
I think if the government knows anything
about ufo is they know barely more than
the average person knows and they have
some evidence and they keep that shit
under wraps with they have cleared up
some evidence.
Perhaps.
Maybe if it's true,
maybe you know,
you hear all the area 51 stories and the
roswell stories and you know,
the crashes has been recovered all over
the country.
There's has been crashes,
recovered supposedly in Pennsylvania,
in the woods,
and who knows how much of that shit's
bullshit.
Who knows how much of that stuff is just
some sort of a prototype that the us
government was working on.
It didn't work and it crashed.
You know who the fuck knows,
but I'm open.
I'm open to the possibility that that's
just the fact that we exist to ants.
Okay?
Then that means the way the universe
works,
things become ever more complicated to
keep going in the same direction over
and over again.
If human beings came from emmy buzz and
all sudden someday evolve to become
human beings,
what?
Whatever the fuck.
We were a single celled organisms that
we became us.
There's gonna be a similar group of
evolution from us to something else,
so it literally will be.
The aliens will be treating us the same
way we treat a fucking ant colony.
Look at these silicons.
I'll get these silly concert,
their pollution.
They're stupid building.
See,
I'm hoping what it is is these ships
that come,
right?
They come and they start talking to us
and then eventually it started to open
up and they come on,
they look exactly like us,
right?
They look exactly like us and what it is
we've spent.
We've spread.
Maybe we've got,
maybe they got like and know.
We're like ants,
right?
They got similar.
What's so great about us?
So then we get in this thing and you get
to go to another planet instantly with
our technology and it's got more space.
It's not all.
There's no pollution and they've,
you know,
sorta like that.
That's what I'm kinda hoping for.
And that's why I'm kind of angling for.
I'm hoping for that.
You want utopia.
That's beautiful.
You should write a book saying that you
know,
it's true.
You don't start a call.
Yeah.
And then drink a bunch of grape kool aid
and they have to go crazy.
That was an africa,
isn't it?
Uh,
it was a diana.
Yeah.
Was it cool to diana tragedy?
Jon jones?
It's ncd amazing,
isn't it?
That self american radio was south
America,
Guyana,
south Guyana
in south America.
As you heard the audio,
are you fucking crazy?
Scary,
so scary.
If you don't know the story of jim jones
was a cult leader,
moved all of his people to Guyana,
wherever that is.
I thought it was africa,
sounds african and they all drank,
drank.
He made them all poison themselves and
then they shot a bunch of people to.
We didn't want to take the poison
congressmen flew down there to see them
and uh,
you know,
the way they poisoned them was they put
the cyanide in grape kool aid and that's
why they,
they,
they say don't drink,
don't drink the koolaid.
That's where that saying comes from.
Yeah.
And that's the,
you know,
the pretty major it.
It resulted in a saying cultural.
Yeah.
Cultural tag.
Don't treat pissed about that to you.
Why would they,
when they're so delicious,
they worry.
Why would truly give a fuck?
Because they're connected to a mass
murder for a long time.
I wonder how we should research,
find out what their sales were up or
down.
That's probably why hawaiian punch was
born.
Probably came out after that.
They changed their name.
You might be rankeD top green.
I think that's a good note to end it on.
Absolutely.
This has been awesome.
Is a lot of fun.
We've been on for like a couple of hours
or something.
Two hours.
That's amazing.
Let's go because we get to go into depth
about subjects,
you know?
I find that like when we were doing an
hour,
we would just start talking about
things.
Then all of a sudden we'd run out of
time and I'm like,
why can't we just keep going?
I love what you said that when I was on
your show,
it was just so much fun.
It's like it seems like it'd be more fun
if we got to keep going.
It's just to get into a really time.
Really.
Cool.
Thank you very much.
Very much for doing it,
man.
I appreciate you coming by and it's so
awesome that I can just run into brian
and I'd love to have you come back and
do the webinar vision deficit soon.com
and run into each other at a comedy club
and then all of a sudden,
boom,
you know,
we're.
We're hanging out in pocket.
That show that you did is actually on
time.
Green.com
right now.
You can go watch it and follow me on
twitter at tom green live and tom green
if you,
if you haven't seen his show,
he has a whole web.
We were talking about the show.
He and I did his whole like literally
like a tonight show on the internet.
It's a brilliant thing and I loved it
and it inspired me to do this.
This was the first thought in my mind of
putting something together on the
internet.
You get my tour dates on there.
Come see me in san francisco this
weekend.
Convert tom green,
tom green.com,
and at tom green live it'll link to it
also,
but on the.
On twitter,
but I'm an cobb's comedy club in san
francisco this weekend.
I've never been there before.
That's fucking awesome.
Yeah.
Great club.
And then uh,
um,
minneapolis and the next week and then
Canada.
Powerful kennedy's coming home.
But just.
Alright.
Thank you very much everybody.
We will see you probably it looks like
next wednesday,
monday or wednesday depending on who I
can get for next week.
But uh,
thanks for tuning in and love you
bitches
on this one.
The dog is on the phone.
No.